it takes a lot of confidence for me to
come on the internet and say some of the
things I say knowing the amount of hate
I'm gonna get for you I feel sixth grade
bro you failed six I didn't feel so
great just how do you maintain a
six-pack year round I'm gonna win I'm
gonna get up I'll go to work and do the
same thing I did yesterday the best day
of a man's life is the day he realizes
that nobody's come to save him can I
just say something I'm so sorry I don't
mean to cut you off yeah yeah that
doesn't make you a man
sleeping with a bunch of women doesn't
make you a man
what makes you a man is that you
[Music]
a lot of people they know you from I
feel like the association with Andrew
Tate a lot of your Clips they go viral a
lot of people have kind of grouped you
into that red pill Community yeah but
I've also heard you on some other
podcasts like I saw you on Tom Billy
used podcast and then a few other
podcasts I've listened to and you're
very articulate and you're not the way
that I feel like a lot of people picture
you to be I've said things that I wish I
could see differently you understand
what I'm saying particularly to women on
panel shows I think I misrepresented
where my heart is
you understand what I'm saying I don't
hate women
and I don't think women are trash
and
I do believe the things that I say
however I don't think I've had an
opportunity to be put on a platform
where I could show who I am particularly
where my heart is the platforms that you
do go on especially those panels there's
a little more aggressive you know it is
I feel like there are certain incentives
it's very incentivized to do that yes
right and listen man I'm not I'm not a
perfect person
you know I think I think that in the
very beginning I was probably in a place
where
I might have said some things
because of that setup now those shows I
do believe are very important and those
men that run those shows I love very
much and I'll always be loyal to them
and even on the last you know I went on
a panel Show recently and it was very
good friends of mine that I love very
much I'll be very clear about this yeah
who was it it was uh fresh and fit and
in the comments they were coming after
me because I was being so quiet
and I'm just at a place after this first
couple of years it's like I just don't
feel good about embarrassing a girl you
know what I mean for me
it's
it's just how I feel about it you know I
think what they do is very important
though I think that they shine a light
on the apps like
how do I say this correctly because
these are these are my friends man and I
love these guys yeah sure they shine a
light on female nature that I think and
the normal man would not see or
understand at the extreme
and I think why they're so beneficial is
because the normal man is so soft that
when they see this and they're this way
I hope and believe that they kind of
land in the middle okay with a firm you
know frame and I do think frame is very
important between a man and a woman I
think on social media to what you were
saying about the comments is that you're
rewarded for saying things that are
extreme because that not only gets the
views it gets all the comments it gets
all the followers
it financially incentivizes you in so
many ways to like how far can we push
this let's keep going more and more and
more why wouldn't you as a business
decision it's just it seems as though if
if that's what's getting results you
would tend to lean towards and when
people are cheering you on over and over
and over again it's hard
I think it's that I think it's um it can
be that way
but just like any man if you evaluate
your situation and you identify
something you don't like I'm sure you've
both done this in your own life in some
form of capacity is something about your
life you can just step up and fix it
you know and
I don't think that I'm on this active
campaign to go tell everybody that I'm
trying to fix it what's really important
to me is I see all of me because I
genuinely believe if they see all of me
I'm palatable to all kinds of shows like
this one like the one I did earlier
today with Ryan Panetta man that guy's
Incredible You know guys like Ed
Marlette I've met him recently and I
think he's just freaking salt to the
earth type guy
and so I just I just believe that if I
can show truly who I am
that I can in the long run maybe not the
short term
do just as good if and not better well
let's talk a little bit more about those
characteristics and who you truly are in
a little bit because we also want to
discuss I mean you've gone on the record
to say that you have businesses that
generate up to 35 million dollars a year
in Revenue correct collectively
collectively yes collectively and your
story is actually very impressive
because your whole appeal or your poll
in the beginning was the fact that you
built up a business in like the real
world I mean you did construction built
up a multi-million dollar business
running a construction company can we
talk maybe just briefly about how you
got into that what led you to
construction and then what did you do
uniquely that got you successful I think
that's very admirable but I think that's
so underrepresented right now is the
trades yeah and a lot of this this jobs
that are just not being showcased online
a thousand percent man these guys build
the world
like the world does not go around
without the men that that build the
country in in every country we couldn't
even do this podcast right now if it
weren't for Tradesmen and I'll tell you
I believe in 10 years there's going to
be YouTubers out there saying you want
to know what the new hack is become a
plumber I've been saying that no I said
that five years ago yeah yeah and I did
a whole video breakdown this is one of
my earlier the doctors
and I did the announcement I'll watch
that video yeah I'll watch that video I
did the announcement I believe you for
those that don't know I broke down the
average salary of a plumber starting at
the age of 18 it goes to trade school
versus that of a doctor who goes into
law school or not law school medical
school debt I think it was up until
about 40 in the 40s the plumber was
ahead financially how he catches up
exactly yeah and so it wasn't until the
doctors in this in like the 50s does the
wealth really take off because they're
just making so much money but up until
that point the plumber comes out ahead
or whatever the um income of the polymer
I remember was pretty conservative as
well yeah I actually looked up how long
it takes to be like a plumber's
Apprentice you did that video years ago
yeah I'll watch that video and uh
it's funny I just finished working I
know where I'll watch that video yeah
because it's so crazy man I watched that
video and the Whole Foods parking lot
Town Center in Baton Rouge Louisiana
eating chicken I propped it up I drive
F-150 yeah in Louisiana I propped it up
and I'm sitting there eating chicken in
the truck I'll watch that video and I
agree with you then and think that was
years ago it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen and it needs to happen
um we live in a world where you can
shake your ass on Tick Tock and make
more money than the guy that paved the
road for me to get here yeah that's
obviously not against the law but I
think it is kind of a
Injustice of equity in the world for
sure and um I've been pitching this
thing called Bob man a Beer by the man a
beer where anytime I see a Tradesman and
he's trying to buy lunch checking out at
the end of the day trying to buy his
12-pack on the way home I try my best to
talk him in and let me do it and and
oftentimes he lets me I think I'm gonna
have to tweak the program a little bit
because I think that it's kind of hard
for the normal person and I get like a
post or two a day
but I think I think it's kind of hard
like I'm gonna have to find another way
to appreciate them because it's kind of
hard to talk a man that's been working
like they're they're also they have
pride and they don't want to take a
selfie with you because you bought on
beer what I'm trying to do is use my
following to
at a minimum
hero the people that build this country
the plumbers The Carpenters
you know the concrete guys the
electricians the sheet rocks the
painters the roofers you know a lot of
these guys put their life online this
dangerous work it's hot work it's or
it's cold the conditions are never good
I don't think they get paid enough
um right in line with cops and teachers
I have I don't agree with curriculums
but I do think teachers are very
important I think they sacrifice their
them their lives for people in a lot of
ways because I'm in construction because
I'll work construction my whole life
I have a heart for them yeah I've been
close to them I've argued with them I've
cursed at them they've cursed at me
wrong like look you know Iron Workers
aren't freaking Boy Scouts bro they're
not man they fight in the hotel rooms
and they get drunk in trucks and they do
you know crazy things but if without
these guys man the world doesn't run
and because of my background and how I
was able to make my first money I just
refused to forget about those guys man
and so the whole campaign was about you
know if you see a guy in work boots
buying his lunch you can tell he's
working trash guy anything any of these
jobs that make the world go
try your best to see if he'll you know
tell him Hey listen I'm a part of this
campaign called Batman the guys that
make the world go round would you please
let me buy you lunch or would you please
let me cover that for you it mean a lot
to me and that's it man
um that's that's I just want to Champion
these guys more because I don't think
they get the credit they deserve and I
don't think people realize how important
they are but before we go into that you
guys know here on the iced coffee hour
we like to be quick and efficient and I
like to cook which is not the most quick
and efficient thing and on busy days I
usually just end up going to the nearest
fast food restaurant because I don't
want to spend time cooking but hear me
out guys all of these problems can be
solved with one simple answer and that's
our sponsor cook Unity cook Unity is the
first chef to you meal delivery service
made up of over 70 chefs who believe
that great high quality food should be
for everybody especially by the way for
parents and entrepreneurs who don't want
to spend their time going to the grocery
store spending time in traffic in line
getting home making the food it's time
consuming or if you're Graham and you're
just a bad cook overall with cook Unity
meals are delivered fresh never Frozen
and the menu rotates every week so
there's always something new to try each
week award-winning chefs craft hundreds
of globally inspired meals with over
seven different dietary preferences
including vegan paleo and gluten-free
options each meal takes just a few
minutes to heat up and I can personally
attest just how fresh and flavorful they
are this meal is spicy pulled chicken
tacos from Ruben Garcia and it was
delicious also cook unity's subscription
is super flexible and you could pause
skip weeks or cancel it anytime this is
great for people like us because we have
to travel so much for podcasts in fact
we're leaving tomorrow and I've got some
cook unity in the refrigerator so I'm
just saying it helps out a ton so check
out cookunity.com ich or use promo code
ich 50 to get 50 off your first order
again that's cookunity.com ich or use
the link Down Below in the description
to get started today and now with that
said let's get back to the podcast why
are they underpaid and why don't they
get that credit well I think they're
underappreciated because it's not a sexy
job
look man I've been on dates with girls
in my past and
I told her that I owned a company that
did metal buildings in structural steel
and I could just see the look on her
face
like she didn't even understand that I
make more money than the guy with the
startup that she went out with the night
before you know what I'm saying it's
like nobody Associates any kind of
status or any kind of
respectability to it
and I have my
thoughts on what really makes it hard
for them I believe that when we went off
the gold standard we went from a guy
that could go put a tool belt on and
support his family completely to his
wife having to work
and I I think that was very negative
through the nuclear family
but in regards to how they're being paid
if I were in charge of construction in
America or was the president or not that
I ever would run for anything like that
or some kind of office I would put
certified payroll bacon like Davis bacon
projects which means they have to check
the payroll and they assign like an
electrician makes this much money with
this much for instance fringe benefits
and a metal building guy makes this with
this much fringe benefits I would make
every project in America that and one of
the big reasons I would do that is
because a lot of contractors smaller
contractors but contractors nonetheless
big ass cash
and don't pay the guys correctly I'll
pay my guys to ride to the project
although the cash I've seen a lot of
non-citizens get paid cash that seems to
be the go-to or people that don't want
to pay their tax isn't that yeah to a
benefit but someone's request hey pay me
cash man so I'd rather get paid 200
bucks right now than 300 and have to
deal with all the IRS yeah I get that
but the problem is that
I want to build my because I'm an
American right I believe in the American
dream I get a lot of flack for taking up
for America but you don't want to be in
America get out because America's a goat
scoreboard and I don't mind paying the
taxes I don't mind taking the taxes out
matching it I would like an equal
playing field
because what what is it so so my
workman's comp for hanging steel is like
45 on 100. before Social Security FICA
medicate everything
so by the time you get close to a 50
labor burden and I'm bidding against a
guy for a million dollar job and he
beats me by two or three hundred grand I
know where it came from
you see what I'm saying and in regards
to
paying paying guys cash I can't sleep at
night trying to build a company on
something I could go to jail for
so we pay it like if when they leave my
office from Louisiana to California
let's say because I got guys from
California to New York right now today
they get paid to ride
they get paid they're 40 hours straight
they get paid overtime
and they get paid per diem and we cover
their hotels
but because of that it makes it hard for
me to do jobs let's say in the South as
much
because
the guy next door will pay him cash
but I'm out here talking about having a
business
and talking about building something
that I can count on for a long time it's
not worth it for me to go to jail
it's not worth it for me to have keep an
eye open and worry about like getting in
trouble with the IRS or the government
it's just not worth it
if it were up to me
I would probably give
because you said something a second ago
with the Spanish guys where you said
non-citizens but if you go on on a
construction site in America right now
and you say
everybody that's not originally born in
America has to leave you'd have a site
superintendent
you probably have an electrician and a
plumber
but other than maybe some HVAC guys the
MEPS other than that you'd lose the
whole job
every damn near every man out there
Spanish
and they're coming in and taking the
jobs that not
Americans want that Americans don't want
you know I look I've got I've got Crews
of American guys honestly they don't
perform the same way but sometimes they
can get into an industrial setting you
know sometimes they can get into an oil
and gas plant
and it's a slower pace and
but I don't think the Spanish guys are
taking jobs from Americans that want
those jobs I don't because I don't have
I don't have American citizens banging
down my doors to come hang steal and I
don't think that's Americans fault
either I'm not blaming Americans for
that I just think that there's a
perception it's all about what you can
be grateful for right your expectation
versus your reality and I think the
average American young man particularly
is growing up in a world that he feels
like he failed if he's not drop shipping
from a beach and it's not cool anymore
to be proud of your work and I know
those guys are out there in rural towns
and stuff I'm not saying that there's no
let's say white guys out there you know
doing their best in construction but I
think by and largely
if an American lands in a construction
role currently
especially one where he's not the owner
or doesn't have a high paying job or
he's not a project manager he's not
particularly I get messages every day
hey man I'm trying to get off my tools
you know
um
and I think that I think that we created
that in America but from my perspective
if I hear someone say I'm in
construction I want to get out of it I
want to I want to do better I want to do
better for my family I just here not
making enough money it's not scalable it
it takes a brutal toll on my body yeah I
want to do something that I can scale
that I could make money without having
to be on the job site all day which I do
not get it is is an objective a lot of
people a thousand percent but um also I
mean it's a one percent for a reason man
they really wanted that I think they'd
find a way if I'm being fair and then I
think some guys love what they do
you know and there are some Americans
out there I don't want to take this away
from all people but I think everybody in
construction knows that a huge portion
is Spanish right when you say Spanish
you mean Hispanic right like people that
speak Spanish yeah so uh Guatemalans
yeah panamanians Mexicans things like
that yeah for sure and I see it in other
countries too every time I go to Dubai
you know it's they're all pulling people
from other countries I'm curious
when did you get into the construction
business you you went to high school
were you good in high school you were
academic and everything did you no man I
wasn't I failed sixth grade bro you
failed six years sixth grade just yeah
there's nothing everyone just gives you
a password it's just you know man like
no you know I I
foreign
like I said home life wasn't the best
yeah I don't want to blame them I wasn't
even a decent student until early high
school I graduated 3-2 in high school I
was in the Key Club but that is a fight
it was a fight Oh I thought you said you
fought no it was a it was a fight
um I got in plenty of fights in sixth
grade in sixth grade yeah I got arrested
in sixth grade for fighting what did you
get
okay well hold on how did you get into
this fight and then why did you get
arrested from this fight always look
well first of all let me backtrack it
sounds like two separate incidents right
yeah how did we go how did we no no it
was just a fight to to do well in school
I wasn't interested okay I wasn't
interested at all like and that's why I
was talking about the curriculums right
uh have you ever heard of the book The
War on boys there's a book about
basically like how things are not really
set up for boys I'm not a 10 10 4 Hatter
on this or anything like that but I do
believe that when what power to you in
sixth grade 12. yeah something like that
sure you really want to sit there and
read like egg around and Poe no no bro
right
it's not interesting I I believe that
little boys at that age
if if I could make the curriculums
they'd be changing tires like learning
how to frame a wall learning how to
change some shoes right yeah I love that
man right how to draft up a contract did
put him to work yeah yeah like actually
works and see if they pointed it out as
a young kid what you're trying to
instill in them you're not necessarily
giving them knowledge that they can use
later in life you're teaching them how
to learn and you're teaching them
discipline well it's really critical
those are the two things that are
actually valuable as a kid but they've
determined that in order to teach kids
how to learn and discipline it's through
homework homework and reading Edgar
Allan I think just like well basic
reading skills I think are important
basic math skills but then I think it's
critical thinking a thousand percent and
I'll tell you another thing too is that
in America particularly I can't speak
for other countries but
if you're not in a point in your life
where you care about the subject
you know I don't think you're gonna hear
it I am more into geopolitics and and
social studies today than I have ever
been I watch Wendover videos I watch
Johnny Harris videos just trying to
understand your channels yeah bro he's
good now that's great wendovers yeah
smoke bro and like we nerd out we're
sending each other videos about you know
why the Mississippi River is the most
powerful river in the world um Scott too
yeah bro bro I don't know out on these
on this at night man and uh
and you could have shown me that video
in sixth grade and I'd have been like
trying to pass a note to some little
girl or throw paper across the room at
my friend that's on the football team or
just whatever it was man I was just not
interested but I think if if little boys
could do things with their hands learn
how to do things that are going to be
helpful in the world that'll also help
the little girls and I'm not even
opposed to teaching little girls how to
change a tire I'm not opposed to that
I'm just saying for the little boys
I don't think it's something that they
resonate with at that age and I was just
completely checked out I was thinking
about football practice
or whatever else you know and um it's
certainly not because I'm not
intelligent I just didn't care and I
didn't make good grades I didn't want to
do my homework and I sure as hell didn't
want to study for a test that I didn't
care about
so
it was just you know one of those things
now I was labeled a 504 student
it's like uh it's like the kind of kid
that like needs his test ringtone oh God
okay it is what it is and I look back at
that time in life I think it was good
for me so as you're about to hear
shortly running a business smoothly can
be fairly challenging trying to keep all
of your goals tasks and data organized
among several softwares could be quite
confusing and often takes more time than
it's worth well if you want to help
restructure your business you don't know
where to start just remember these three
numbers from our sponsor netsuite it's
thirty six thousand twenty five and one
thirty six thousand because over 36 000
companies have already upgraded to
netsuite and stopped wasting time on
things like manual data entry and
sifting through scattered data 25
because netsui has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their
costs and one because netsui is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage all of your kpis or key
performance indicators with one
efficient system netsuite helps reduce
the mistakes of manual data entry and
trust me guys with manual data entry
there will always be mistakes and they
also help prevent the busy work scaling
with your business so get a full picture
of your your business and help make
better decisions faster so make sure to
download netsuite's popular kpis
checklist for free right now at
netsuite.com iced once again guys it's
netsuite.com iced and get your free kpi
checklist today once again guys it's
free and it's netsuite.com iced thank
you so much netsuite and back to the
podcast but how do you go from there to
getting arrested there's there's a big
okay yeah the sixth grade fight to
arrest I I can't stop thinking about I
feel like we gotta address that I'll
tell you
um we lived in a neighborhood
when
before I moved to this town called Denim
Springs and it was um I was like the
only white kid
and I learned a lot from the culture of
being the only white kid and seeing
certain things since a lot there was a
lot of fights in that neighborhood I
moved to this all white school pretty
much and some kid popped off to me and I
was hard
at that time and I busted them up pretty
good and uh what did he say to you dude
I can't even remember now he was just
how did it how did it make you feel at
the time though I bet you remember the
emotions that went through your mind as
soon as you said that it was actually
one of those things where it's like all
right cool catch me when you get off the
bus
so he lived in the front of the name I
can't believe I'm even saying this he
lived in the front of the neighborhood
and he walked from the front of the
neighborhood all the way the back of the
neighborhood
and I met him in the street and it was
you versus him yeah and some parents
broke it up and you actually like it was
a fight fight yeah of course who threw
the first punch was that you or was he
you're talking to two guys who have
we've never been into it well I've been
in a fight I just lost were you actually
in a fight with Michael Michael
he did a boxing match
oh god I've been in yeah four or five
fights in my adult life okay oh but
that's actually kind of common in the
South people in the South no I think
yeah and look I'm not championing this
either I'm not sitting here saying
it's cool I don't feel cool or manly to
tell you about this just in case
no I'm just telling you man because I
know there's gonna be always young men
watching what I say and so
um you know if I can back away from one
today I will now if I can't you get
close enough I'm gonna hit you first
where do you know the line between
walking away and standing up for
yourself really good conversation with
Patrick
if the other kid swings first you gotta
defend yourself and that's up to you if
you can't de-escalate yeah there's
something fight back there's actually
something that you said in there that I
would teach my son differently sure and
or Patrick said maybe
is he has to hit you first my personal
rule
is I'm gonna tell you I don't want to
and I'm gonna try to step away
but if you get back in range
there's definitely a jab cross coming I
will definitely hit you first because I
don't want to fight you in the first
place and the mistake I made in that bar
is after he hit the floor I tried to
ground by the back I dropped to a knee
and tried to grab him by the back of the
head and really wear his ass out and
when one of his buddies came up behind
me
actually a bit bigger than me and I just
got lucky because I was able to get it
and they were all three trying to hit me
but I was kind of covered up because he
was over me and
it just like I don't I don't promote
fighting if I leave here today
and somebody tries to fight me and I
think I can walk away I absolutely will
regardless of Pride or ego
but when they get you in a corner I'm
not going to wait for them to hit me
first I already know they want to hit me
you know I've been in enough fights to
know what his eyes look like what his
intentions are I can see his his this
balled up you know and then you and then
when you actually get in a fight you get
this very shaky feeling inside of you
it's like it's actually very you know
it's it's like a bone chilling feeling
it's the adrenaline coming in your body
so you can like not feel things
and uh I know what that's like I know
it's I know when somebody has an
intention I've been in I've been in at
least 12 15 in my life
so I know what it's like and I'm also
not the only time I've ever met somebody
for a fight was that fight I was telling
you about everything else is spur of the
moment everything else was you know boom
boom
and it's over quick man have you ever
lost a fight no I'm not well
third grade I got my nose busted yeah I
got my nose busted you got your nose but
your hands bleeding and everything yeah
everywhere oh yeah how that has been I
got in a fight with this kid I can't
believe we're talking about okay this is
the last fight and then we're gonna go
to all the inspiring okay business
building and then we got other you know
stuff in store I didn't know you were so
interested in the subject y'all y'all
should have had Tate on no no keep going
keep going okay there's this kid messing
with my sister on the bus
I did what I did it went very much in my
favor
and then the next day I was walking off
the bus and he kicked me and he ran to
an open seat and laid down on the seat
and started kicking so when I went to
him no he did that move he just that's
okay that's not a cool it was like a
backwards Turtle kick right I know
exactly went right into it yeah um yeah
so whatever on to the business okay so
so how did you get into construction uh
at a young age and then when did the
money really start coming in
yeah so
um when I was a little boy my stepdad
did metal buildings
and um to be quite honest with you the
type of neighborhoods we lived in when
there was no lawyers there was no
doctors or anything like that and
we had some house fires when I was a kid
and we ended up staying in his boss's
house
when I was in like seventh grade and we
were in a completely different
neighborhood and uh it gave me a new
Consciousness on what was possible
because I had not seen a whole lot of
that I always say that construction was
the only way we knew how to make doctor
money was in Boots
and that's actually
quite a true thing in south Louisiana
you know the mouth of Mississippi's air
so there's a lot of Industry there's a
lot of industrial work there's a lot of
construction that goes with that work
there's a lot of building houses to
support that that infrastructure of the
economy in south Louisiana and
it was the only Consciousness I had I
say all of the time
that had I put the same energy into a
better business model a different
business model
then construction I think I'd be a lot
better off but I don't think I'd be the
same person
and for that I'm glad I stayed in
construction I graduated college in 2009
I'd already read Rich Dad Poor Dad and I
knew I wanted to have a business one day
but I honestly thought I'd end up in
Dallas as a project manager first making
really good money and save and end up
you know starting something and those
jobs just weren't there like we were
told when we were freshmen signing up to
go into construction management school
and so I dug ditches
and I worked for this company called
Austin bridge and Road in this little
small town called Bastrop Louisiana
after I graduated that job ended I went
to Baton Rouge I waited tables at Texas
de Brazil
in Baton Rouge and I would go during the
day and apply for jobs and they were
building this hospital called Women's
Hospital in Baton Rouge in them
I'd gone in there a couple times because
they had they were actually building the
project so instead of going to home
office I was like going out to job sites
and um the ladies like I can't let you
see the boss you know you can see the
boss like 40 50 million dollars some
crazy amount
like the third time I went
she goes hold on so some grizzly looking
angry white man comes he's like are you
Justin I'm like yes sir come with me so
go back to his office and uh he plops
down in his chair and he's like give it
to me and I'm all like you know
he looks at he looks at me he looks at
he looks at me He Flops it on the table
he's like you need to tell me you've
come in here three or four times to stop
a 30 40 million dollar project to see
the boss because you want a job yes sir
well I like that
offer me a job boom
and uh I ended up not taking it I went
to the company down the street six times
they gave me a job so I went to New
Orleans instead but what I did there was
I was making really good money it was a
levy project for the Corps of Engineers
and so it was like government funded so
we all kind of got paid really well I
was making like 60 Grand a year and so
what I did is I went to the bank and I
said listen I get my my checks order
drafted but I want you to push
everything but my per diem
into this other bank account
because I wanted to get a contractor's
license and to get a contractor's
license you had to have a net worth of
ten thousand dollars
which or myself or anybody in my family
had it took me about six months I guess
to get the money saved up now I wouldn't
apply for a residential contractor's
license and then I moved the money to
another bank and went and applied for my
commercial
and that was 14 years ago March now we
have over 200 men 25 States
we do all of America the Caribbean how
do you scale that up from working for
someone else to then going off on your
own is it still a requirement by the way
to have a 10 000 on a net worth to be a
contractor I think it is in Louisiana
you have to prove it yeah and I think
that's a good thing yeah I think it's a
good thing the show is like what
discipline is well just like that or not
yeah like if you can't get a net worth
of 10 grand 10 grand
then you're probably gonna either do
some shady or not do the right
thing or not run the right systems and
maybe even hurt somebody just by
accident construction is really hard
with cash flow like understanding cash
flow like a whip report a work in
progress your billing excess a cost cost
and accessibility once you start getting
into millions of dollars you really need
to understand cash flow
and
and a lot of guys like if you can't get
a ten thousand dollar net worth you're
not going to understand AR you're not
going to understand retainage and
billing and how you really have to play
with the big boys to be able to even be
a subcontractor you're really just not
it's it and I think that's a good rule
when I started off
2500 payrolls like two or three guys I
went to I never forget my first line of
credit was fifteen thousand dollars
First American Bank bag the lady to get
a line of credit because I had twenty
five hundred dollar payrolls and at that
time that was a whole lot of money to me
and we were doing these 30 by 40s and
backyards we're doing sheds man
and uh I'm 24 25 so I keep a tool belt
in the truck for the guys that didn't
show up to work then I put slacks in
there so I could go beg for money at the
bank and a polo to go try to sell a job
and I did that and I worked out of an
F-150 for
four years five years how are you
getting jobs and what year was this by
the way this would have been 2011 is
when I started kind of rough time I mean
not the easiest time no because that was
the the lowest point for housing was
yeah 2011. yeah
um but we were doing metal buildings and
um
and so I would do that
and then I eventually got to a place
where
I knew I needed more systems and so I
got really heavy into e-myth
and I worked with emith for about a year
and a half what's even e-myth is a book
by Robert E Gerber it talks about the
entrepreneur the manager and the
technician
and so having that insight for me was
actually really important because I
had a really good understanding of what
I had to be to my business and what did
I what did I need to replace myself with
I needed a really really good technician
to really help me you know with the guys
and because the buildings were getting
bigger and bigger and more complex so
when you go from the backyard
to doing a school project in New Orleans
it's no longer
columns purlins and girts it can be CMU
block within beds and trusses
it can be
a normal metal building but there's a
standing seam roof now there's a valley
and so there's these all these intricate
details that now I can literally in my
mind see but it's only because damn near
every roof I did for the first
three years of commercial leaked
and and I had to go get all these
certifications I had to go to
Pennsylvania to get certified to do
Butler mr-24 roofs which are on every
Costco in America by the way
I had to get go to do the new core
you know test to make sure I knew how to
put their roof on because every
manufacturer has a little bit of a
different detail so they can get their
you know their patent on it and so in
the specs that the architect writes
which is again completely different than
doing a backyard Mueller building you
have to be qualified
to do these roofs because a lot of times
I have what's called a no dollar 20-year
warranty on it which means the
manufacturer comes out with a feeler
gauge a camera and anything he can to
poke holes in and take a bunch of photos
and then make these 20 Page reports and
they're like no you have to do this this
and this and this and they'll hold your
money until you do it and so making the
jump from the backyard a commercial
I took some blows how do you get jobs
like that because those are pretty
substantial jobs yeah so I'll tell you
exactly what I did
so
I
sought out mentors I would say around
26. there's this organization called the
metal building contractors Directors
Association
shout out to Sasha and it's a mouthful
to say could you say that again metal
building contractors and Erectors
Association I'm still part of it the way
that flows and so I sought out
mentorship and there was guys at
companies like there's a company in New
Jersey named Thomas Phoenix Sean Eric
Gary they really took me under the wing
they were really good to me they really
helped me and they gave me a proposal
template
and um I took their name off of it put
mine on it made sure I understood it
but it made me look big on paper we
weren't big we had like two trucks you
know but it made us look it made us look
legit
and then I know that every project has a
pre-job walk
and so that means that every General so
because we work for General Contractors
right so a big GC we do the steel we
only do steel right we don't do
everything else that's General so we
work for gc's so I knew that the
Architects made the GCS do a pre-job
walk before like if they don't show up
to that they can't bid it so I started
calling The Architects and asking for
the pre-job walk form because I knew
like two gc's at this time
so I might get one invite out of ten
general contractors for the same job
or
I could find out everybody that's bitten
it and non and just send my bid anyway
so what I ended up doing is making what
we call now a pre-qualification package
which was like a company resume right
and I would send them a bid and say hey
I know bid days crazy good luck I hope
y'all kill it today
but instead of building up bidding a
hundred thousand dollar job to one GC
I'd send it to 10 and I had scenarios
where
I would win the job and then the GC that
didn't win would have Steel on the
ground
and need somebody
and so I ended up getting on all these
people's bid lists and when I did that a
higher estimator
and then we built a very strong system
around every panel we put in every kind
of column of framed opening on the steel
a framed opening on shooting the wall to
trim out everything so the the
spreadsheet
I worked on for years just fine-tuning
every little thing to spit out man hours
because what's dangerous in our business
of people a square foot something but if
it has 47 windows in it you're going to
be there an extra two or three weeks you
know so for every little thing that we
at any kind any kind of material we've
ever installed
we have a man-hour budget to put in set
amount per day
and that way I could trust
that if my estimator which was like a 55
year old man at the time when he was he
was with me for like six seven years
if he just puts the data incorrectly if
he just sees the drawings correctly and
reads the details that it would spit me
out a number that was competitive and so
what he would do
is he would send me three or four a week
and we ended up getting to where I've
been three to five a week every week
and what I would do is I was running
between jobs I was like my own general
superintendent at this time he would be
back in the office I'd be visiting all
the job sites all over the place
and I'd pull over still Wi-Fi off my
phone open a Macbook go over it with
them on speakerphone look at the
drawings with them just to double and
triple check
and um we'd spit three to five bids out
a week and then we started doing
millions in revenue and then I had my
next problem is scaling the Manpower and
then making sure the systems
put me in a place where I could trust
that the work would be done correctly so
even today we have what's called a
project process every mistake we've ever
made ever made
from unloading the truck to shaking the
steel out
to hanging the steel to sheeting the
walls to putting the roof on to seaming
the roof to blowing the roof off to
putting the gutters on and making sure
that we don't cut the gutter for a
downspout where subsurface drainage is
coming up let's say because they're not
going to move from out of the ground so
guess who's got to buy a new gutter if
it's one foot off all these things that
have happened right that list is there
and it's every mistake we've ever made
and we run that list to make sure our QC
runs well and then of course we have uh
safety we have a safety guy
and we have
a girl that makes sure that they turn
jsas in every day and that when the time
sheets are turned in or if they go into
the app t-sheets
that is coded to the right thing because
one of the most powerful things that you
can possibly have in construction is
historical data for estimating so that
spreadsheet I was talking about with
those man hours factors for us to know
how correct they are
it makes a lot of sense for us to be
able to have really strong books
and I think having strong books and
construction particularly trade
construction
is one of the most important things a
guy could do because if you don't know
the historical data of what got you to
the profit or not profit on the job then
you're going to make the mistake again
yeah how often are you unprofitable on
the jobs because I'd imagine and I've
seen it before where a contractor will
bid a job be a bit under and if they're
held to it sometimes we're losing money
because they just underestimate how much
work goes into I've lost money on a
bunch of jobs man in fact in that phase
in that growth phase
it would really look like this make a
bunch of money
break even break even lose money make a
Break Even lose a little bit make a
little bit lose money
it was it
and that's really it was really around
scaling
you know you got this one guy that's
like your Ace and you want to put them
on the best job you can and you still
have guys not showing up
you still have blood on projects
you still have steel showing up
incorrectly you have forklifts breaking
down you have manless breaking down you
have trucks stolen
you know I I it's nothing for me to get
a call on a Sunday and be like the guy's
just gotten a big bar brawl in Michigan
and cops are looking for trucks with
your logo on it sweet these things
happen it is construction and so just
like getting like planting seeds with
men cutting the bad ones keeping the
good ones planting seeds with men
cutting the bad ones and now I have
three good ones now I have four what
makes them bad and can you spot that
ahead of time when hiring are there red
flags that you see in people I could
kind of tell this might go there I can
tell you when it turned around for me I
created a system around hiring I'm a big
fan of Patrick lincione's books so he's
got the ideal team player which is a
very cool book it's actually about
trying to find a construction guy and
then that's just by coincidence but he's
got hump he's got this thing called
humble hungry smart but what we start
with is proven competence I used to
would run ads for guys and they would
call they would lie about how long
they've been doing it they've been
working at the competition for three
months and they tell you they've been
there five years and they'd want to
leave you to get a raise or whatever it
is and um so what I did is I was like
okay War I need to be
recruiting
at least 1.25 more than I'm bidding
and always draw a circle on the on the
board at my office I'm like bids
recruiting and then the projects right
in the middle
and
so what I did is I created very loaded
metal building questions that you would
only know if you've been doing it for
quite some time after we've proven
competence
I think the best part of this this phone
process starts humble hungry smart would
you be willing to work under another
form and to learn our systems
for a little while until you learn how
we do it cool
that's that's you know a big question
would you be willing to work for a
dollar an hour less for the first month
so we can see you're as good as you say
you are hungry
would you be willing to leave town
and work weekends if we need you to to
hit a schedule smart
tell me what you don't like
about your current company we're trying
to get them to talk like we're
truly trying to get them to like we we
really push them on this one test if
they if they don't if they talk
they're out but then again they're
trying to be honest with you if you ask
them what you don't like yeah but I've
done I've done enough I've done honest
because they'll run with it sure they
will run with it
and there's a big difference between you
know
I don't really like it here I don't feel
like I get treated very well I'll leave
it at that or I don't see growth here
um
and I'm not
maybe maybe they haven't come through on
the Promises they gave me things like
that versus sure these MF they're trash
blah blah they're idiots the one the
guys in the office are morons they don't
know how to estimate probably the last
thing I need in my business is that guy
talking to my guys
right
and then look
we asked them
how their luck is how are things going
for you how's your life going
and when you have guys that come to you
telling you how unlucky they are they
will bring that bad look into the
company
and
what I do because I'm not on these calls
and neither is my operations manager
so
have you ever heard of the Fibonacci
series no I have not so it's like this
concept that most things in nature are
an odd number and that humans
struggle seeing the difference between
two and three we can definitely see the
difference between one and five five and
nine nine and thirteen
that you can feel the difference
and so let's say we get to the question
about Hungary are you willing to work
out of town on short notice or work
weekends if we need you to
well yeah I mean I could do that for
y'all if you really needed me to or yes
absolutely I'll go anywhere you want me
to go I'm here to work
completely different answer both yes
because I'll tell you whatever they they
need you to hear for them to get a job
but the flexion in their voice because
I'm not on the call I can't hear it
but
she rates using the Fibonacci series
how much of a yes it was so 13 being the
highest and then the total score
is anybody over a certain score gets to
talk to Renee and she's our operations
manager and that's how we weed out if I
if we talk to 100 guys
Renee I'll talk to five or six Maybe
but I get rid of all the lies I get rid
of all the drama I get rid of any
incompetency lies
just by these five categories and how
they tell you yes or no but then how do
they squeak by let's just say they get
accepted they start the job but then
after a month or two you realize it's
not working out how do they squeak by
that and what do you notice on the job
that they're lacking is it maybe
discipline are they just not focused
enough is it are they not
detail-oriented enough how do you spot
these things it'll be safety quality
production okay well no if they're
getting kicked I've got like if they're
getting kicked off of jobs for not tying
off
when they know damn good and well they
should be
they signed they put a JSA together
every day
um if they're not hitting man hours I
have enough men now
that if a God tells me he put a thousand
square foot of roof on in a day
that something's not right
you know what I'm saying we have enough
jobs in or we've done thousands of
buildings millions of square foot of
buildings All Over America
we know like our man our man hours
factors are they're solid now we know
what they're supposed to do and then
quality
if they don't want to read the detail
you have to know
and you have to get it right because if
it fails inspection
then you're looking at Insurance claim
of possibly ripping a roof up or massive
amount of extra man hours
for getting this thing in a place where
the manufacturer will actually give the
customer that warranty because we put it
incorrectly and 99 of the time if a roof
leaks 99.9999 of time it is a Rector
error
we are Erectors and those are engineers
and they have tested this in all
conditions so if we don't do the detail
correctly they will not insure the roof
and if they don't insure the roof the
architect won't sign off of and they
won't buy it I'd love to get a little
bit more into the self-development stuff
because you've been also talking about
that a lot recently I feel like how you
have to get fit I have to start earning
a Better Living making more money to be
the best version of yourself that you
can possibly be as somebody watching
this right now that maybe doesn't wake
up and feel super happy with where
they're at in life what would you
recommend they do to start becoming the
best version of themself getting shape
I put it in front of making money I
really do I think that being in shape
gives you an advantage in business
I believe that truly I think people
respect you more I think people look at
you and they say like you it's like
walking discipline
walking strength I look it might not be
a popular thing to say
but a physical stature on a man when he
walks into a room in his ability like I
said to look human eye body language
it Garners respect and it in my opinion
can get you further in business people
people want to work with people they
respect so Fitness first number one if
you're not in shape and you're eating
bad and you're not moving your body
then your whole all your cells are stale
like you can't even think straight so I
always put getting in shape above
everything
you know I believe that a person that
does really well in life and is not in
shape would have done better if they
were in shape you know what on that
though that's the one thing you can't
make you can't fake being in shape you
can't fake a six but I mean I'm sure you
can fake a six-pack but it seems as
though that's the one thing that all
these billionaires are doing is like all
of a sudden they all seem to be getting
in shape getting six packs yeah because
when you have all the money like you
can't necessarily buy that stuff that's
just purely dedication discipline and a
lot of work and so that to me now seems
like the ultimate Flex is being really
in shape thousand percent and it's one
of those you know you could be a very
rich guy and walk through the grocery
store nobody would know
you can't say that about Fitness you get
to carry that with you everywhere you go
it gives you an advantage whether it's
with dopsis X business or even how you
feel about yourself
it's easy to respect yourself when you
put in the work to get in shape you know
because it's hard work
and it shows so I for me that's number
one on the list uh some people would
probably put money in front of it I just
personally don't because I just think
you'll do better at business if you're
in shape particularly sales are free
yeah it is it's costing it yeah thousand
percent yeah and it doesn't take as much
time as people say it does you know I
remember being high school man I worked
at Harbor Freight Tools you know what
that is yeah I do yeah I would go in the
back
in the bathroom and I put the little
sales papers now on the bathroom floor
let's do push-ups until I couldn't do
them anymore you know and I did that for
years and years and years you know and
um it really pays off now because at 37
I've had six shoulder surgeries on this
shoulder
and her total replacement
and I have mature muscle left over from
20 years of exercising and so now I I
don't let myself get any further than
two weeks out from middle to turn take
my shirt off anytime I want you know I
keep ABS year round
but it was all that work I did
especially when I was young you know
like people
people should start working at an early
age because your body is maturing and
growing at that time and you can create
all this bone density all this mature
muscle that will stay with you
over time especially if you just do the
work to keep the maintenance on it I
don't work out the same way I used to my
shoulder really won't allow it some days
it really hurts the Box you know so I
have to work on footwork all day or you
know
defense or whatever but I don't think
there's a thing in this world that you
could do for yourself
I can't think of one that's better than
getting in really good shape and getting
strong this makes me want to hit the gym
well you need to you need to no I do hit
the gym I do go I went today yeah yeah
but yeah but how do you maintain a
six-pack year round what is that like
because that seems to me like your
disciplined every meal like well I'll
tell you everything I'll tell you how I
personally do it
is I've had a six-pack since I was 24
years old there's not been a day between
24 now where I could not see all of my
abs now I might get puffier around the
love handles you know like if you have a
standard you know sometimes I'd be here
sometimes I'd be here but I'd never get
too far imagine if there's a straight
line and there's line above it and below
it I never got outside that I would
never let myself get outside that range
and it's super easy to keep it once you
get it
and even though this is not true I try
to tell young Mando believe that
whatever you get today you'll keep it
forever it'll make you work out harder
so you get the most you can
but
the way I do it now is I I fast every
day I'm still not eating today what I
haven't eaten no what time do you wake
up
today yeah five o'clock AM yeah and it's
like seven it's coffee 30 bro
coffee
I don't get by all day without eating
and I get headaches I'm used to
scattered I'm used to it I'm faster
breakfast and initially it was a little
tough but now it's very easy and I don't
even think about it anymore yeah I feel
like you just get used to it I don't
even think about it and so what do you
have just one meal at the end of the day
yeah yeah and then what time do you go
to bed probably from 10 to 12 on a
normal day so you're eating and then
going to bed right afterwards I heard
that's bad for you to eat like right
before you go to bed everything's bad
for you what do you eat what's a normal
dinner look like for you protein
steak or chicken or whatever but I'll
eat carbs too can you track calories or
it's like the one meal I could do
whatever I want to if I don't yeah if I
want to I eat pizza I eat pizza if I
want to
but I mean and I'm and a lot of people
when they fast
their goal is to trigger like an insulin
response right that's actually not what
I'm trying to do because I'll drink the
little five-hour energies are the feel
free you ever tried one of those I got
like I just stick with coffee they got
like mac and stuff and I drink coffee
too but
um I know the coffee won't trigger the
insulin but even like a fake sweetener
can kind of tell the brain or the gut
like you know you have sugar in you I do
it for Pure mathematical purposes
there's no way I can eat 2500 calories
between 8 pm and 10 pm
like it's almost impossible so for me
it's more about a deficit than it is
about like messing with my insulin
response or anything like that like I
don't nerd out on it I definitely think
there's like an 80 20 to Fitness
you know even even in the way that I
work out
I genuine like
I only do
certain lifts because I know that I'll
get the biggest return from those lifts
and what is that so for example
I'll never do flat bench or D or um
decline bench sure I do all upper chest
when you walk into a room or you're
outside there's one constant variable
and that's overhead light
in a lot of particularly like having a
six-pack or looking big is an illusion
based off light so I focus all on my
upper chest because when you walk in a
room that's what people are going to see
and it also pulls the rest of your chest
up
when I do abs I only do the bottom two
ABS seems oddly specific how well let me
let me let me clarify how many guys have
you met it's like oh I got the top two
we're probably my Grandma's got
to talk to it's your ribs
exactly come on exactly
but
if you do decline
weighted abs like with a 45 on your
chest and you only focus on the bottom
two and you tilt your head back so you
isolate it
nobody in history of the universe has
ever had the bottom two in this V taper
and not have the top two I treat my abs
like I would treat my bicep you ever
seen a guy that's super lean skinny even
any not have a six-pack I I've known
plenty of guys like this and so the
reason I say this and that you have to
treat it like your bicep is that you
need to get a pump in your abs and what
that allows you to do so as the skin
goes down and that muscle is growing and
go back to overhead light that muscle
poking through the skin is what creates
the shadow underneath and so the bigger
you can get them
and it's kind of like that girl thing
like bro you're not gonna your abs
aren't Gonna Get huge overnight you're
not gonna look like you have a huge gut
shut the up try to get a pump where
you can literally feel a physical pump
in your abs
and they poke through the skin and even
you bro you can have a six pack at 12 14
body fat sometimes and then when you
start to actually down then you get
really ripped because it's
poking through the skin and protruding
you know you kind of get that 300 look
I'm telling you you'll have a six-pack
faster than you would anyway it's an
absolute cheat because it pokes through
the skin and it creates a shadow
you know I'm telling you so look
is this cred credit right here well I
could I could just show y'all but I feel
like that'd be turbo douchey so
[Music]
turbo that's funny yeah so you want you
want the poke out oh my gosh yeah you
see what I'm saying but see you got the
V thing going like screaming at me it's
like how do you get the side bit too
here yeah he also airdrop this to me
just so I can show the view is that cool
here's that photo yeah
um you guys gotta see this okay
on the obliques one thing I would say
you could do and I did this a lot early
on is you ever do a side plank yeah okay
cool
go up and put your hand on them make
sure it burns and when it finally starts
to burn
bounce
pulse on that it up like
like want to destroy it I used to do
that two minutes at a time on each side
and I just put into it hurts so bad and
it's just because those are really small
muscles and people are like oh if you do
that every day dude I do abs every time
I have this thing I call Lima Bean
Theory
in Lima Bean theory is for abs you ever
see a guy go to the gym and he says okay
we'll do ads when we're done but what
happens is he goes in there he does
shoulders or whatever he does right I
use this for actually abs and legs
he gets this big pump and then after the
fact when he's supposed to do abs lima
beans me every single time I go yeah
exactly yeah you have to change that
lima bean theory is you're sitting at
the table your mom made macaroni and
cheese chicken nuggets and these stupid
ass lima beans
eat the lima beans first when you have
the most energy pre-workout
excited to be there whatever get it out
of the way
then you can enjoy the chicken nuggets
and the macaroni and cheese
you know it's like goes back to eating
as a kid first do it first because
you're not going to do it after I'll
give you another example tricep
I don't want to start flexing in here
but I kind of want to I know
so like I only work on this inside you
see that little horseshoe and that
horseshoe yeah I only work on those
because any that ever does
triceps ever is going to get this line
right here
so I purposely I'll take my thumbs and a
rope I'll do Skull Crushers heavy
but I'll take my thumbs with the rope
and turn it out and I'll even stand up
I'll take that you know the little ball
that comes on the little board yeah I'll
take that ball
and I'll put it between my fingers like
this and I'll turn and I'll purposely go
over the back so I hit this guy Jesus
yeah yeah and with the bottom two abs
so you got three words no no but that's
that's not that it's not completely true
no I don't because I still I'll still
shrug yeah right when I do my biceps
I'll you know how like there's you know
the weight the weight and the handle
I'll push my hand all the way to the
inside and I'll twist it like as far as
I can out to create that Peak hmm
you understand what I'm saying yeah and
so like Rambo for example I think he
shot Rambo like 158 pounds but he looks
220. it's all a illusion if you
can develop the right muscles now of
course
rep range is important so I do 12 12
working sets of eight as heavy as I can
possibly do and then I'll erupt it fail
twice
you do a lot
it's not really a lot
it's pop sets and I would also I did a
lot of rep to fail push-ups coming up
now I've heard the reason you're not
supposed to do that and like isolate
certain muscles is because of injury so
like when you go and you kind of lift
let's say for your shoulder or
what's that he's trying to block it out
what is that I don't know that
what does that mean only will
tell you that yeah bro people
I thought it was like some Illuminati
yeah
are you a part I'm part of the
Illuminati it's no problem you're not a
part um no no I'm I'm probably accused
of it got it yeah I just wanted to
clarify by the way I've been doing my
hands like this for years okay no no
that's what I want to know okay because
I was actually going to point that out
everyone's been doing this okay even
right I'll notice myself doing it I
swear to God Andrew could type himself
wiping his ass and it would catch on
so I don't know bro I mean but literally
did you get that from Android bro I you
know it's so funny
before I ever met Andrew
oddly enough there's a picture of me at
a war room event before I met Andrew
sitting like this looking at the guy
talking
a lot of people do this really Andrew
made it cool bro Andrew made it cool bro
it was super comfortable you've never
done this I do I I catch myself doing it
but I'm like oh God like is this just
because this is because of Andrew is it
in my subconscious bro you know look
I've been doing it for a long time in
the Illuminati what they would say
though maybe maybe but there's
conspiracy theories everywhere but
anyway back to what we're saying I also
do I do heavy weight I believe in doing
heavy weight I'll do weighted pull-ups
I'll strap a 45 around my waist and do
pull-ups and things like that and then
I'll rep to fail after you know
um I don't claim to be a fitness Guru
but I I do think that there's some very
obvious muscle groups that will give you
an advantage and give you a huge return
on investment of time
and I clearly don't Skip Leg Day
so that's how I look at it yeah so do
you think for most guys it's better to
go to the gym purely for
you know physically being in better
shape or do you think it it's better for
the health reasons I think everything
sure I think mating Business Health bone
health longevity
aging motivation everything man
everything I when I think about working
out when it comes to energy particularly
I think about you're doing that work and
you're like cranking but you like a
little toy car yeah the dial
and like you come out in like this
euphoric State especially if you really
went after it yeah yeah so I do believe
in in lifting heavy and then rubbing to
fail
people like oh you're up to fail you're
going to burn your muscles down it's
like it's like when girls say I don't
want to work out because I don't want to
get big it's like look
sweetheart like I don't know what made
you think that your genetics are better
than every dude in your gym that's
working out every day and he's still not
big like with
one tenth of his testosterone you're not
going to get jacked getting the squat
rack
so
um
I I do and I call them pinpoint muscle
groups so I only work out these certain
muscle groups I probably don't do in a
year any more than
10 or 12 lifts
like all these people that are mixing it
up
and like doing kettlebells hate
kettlebells don't catch me dead doing
kettlebells hey kettlebells bro if I if
you catch me doing kettlebells please
kick me in the nuts
like it's the dumbest on the planet
it's liver King sent us
a whole bunch of cattle belts yeah liver
King also a lot about a bunch of
but he he does the kettlebells for
different reasons he does Barbarian you
know the Barbarian workout is no you
should try it no dude I I carried it was
horrible I he sent them and I was like
I'm gonna just try to see when you put
your hands on them or something so you
hold I think it's 70 pound kettlebells
in each hand yeah I guess it was seven
yeah okay you have 20 pound ankle
weights on each leg you have what is it
a hundred or so pounds in a backpack and
you're dragging a sled that has like I
think 135 pounds and you have to walk a
mile and you can't sit that's
why would you say that because I'm not
trying to be a traffic triathlete I'm
trying to be jacked and explosive
like that's dumb I feel like where's the
hypertrophy in that really your calves
Maybe
like you you might get lean that way
okay cool we're talking about putting on
muscle I think his thing wasn't so much
it was just like I'm gonna push myself I
think he's on so much gear doesn't
matter what he does it was mental
endurance I think that's what for that
for that I'm cool with it if if he's
going to David Goggins route yeah I
think it honestly and it's like a mental
fortitude thing that's like a writing
passage but let's not like like
ideally
you would look like a pro athlete let's
say I think that's the greatest
compliment I've ever gotten is when
somebody asked me who I played for you
know I'm like yeah well that's a long
time over and I don't like to be uncle
rico but thank you what is it like
living life as someone who's six for
it's like being dealt at least two Aces
really yeah bro for sure you're born
straight white male and tall
oh that's at least three Aces out of
five you know you think it's that big of
an advantage to be six four and no no I
would never like
I don't think just because you're tall
you get ahead in life
but I mean there are certain advantages
to it and I think I'd be
but good to say that that's not true
what are some of the biggest advantages
you would say girls
the ability to play sports
um
a certain physical presence in a room I
think it's helped me in leadership of it
but I don't think it I don't think it
makes me a better leader you know I just
think it's helpful but not planes not
good on planes not good on planes not
good in Lamborghini okay
right right right right so no sports
cars but you can reach the top aisle top
shelf yes that's good okay I can
absolutely do that right you know
there's an obvious thing that I can say
that Graham can stand on his wallet
right you know which it is what it is
but you know what also
I've thought about this deeply actually
if I had not been so tall
or would not like gifted so much like
physically I might have created a
different strategy in my life and been
much better at something else does that
make sense it does I 100 actually agree
with you yeah like I would have been
like okay you can't play this card in
life you need to hyper Focus here you
know and I think life is really like
that I think that life is
you know evaluating the hand you're
dealt and then saying okay how can I
maximize this because everything that's
ever happened negative in my life
are any disadvantage that I think I have
like I'm quite dyslexic like I don't
read very well at all my work my eyes
just don't pick the words up yeah it
could be a simple it could be like a
child's book and like I just whatever
the eye flow is it just doesn't work out
very well for me and I'm like okay well
what can I do about it you know so I've
been able to turn most negative things
in my life into positive somehow and I
think winners do that I mean most people
if they have something that seems to be
a disadvantage I try to wait find a way
to make it a superpower I really do you
know like I didn't grow up in the best
situation like I grew up trailer parks
and stuff like that
but for that reason I believe I had this
certain kind of grit or understanding of
the world or whatever that I I choose to
believe whether it's true or not gives
me an advantage
and that's just how I choose to frame it
do you think there's a disadvantage of
being really tall I think much taller
than me you start to look like a baby
giraffe you know what I'm saying okay
you know exactly but you said much
taller than you I mean
is there any disadvantage I would cut it
off at six four you think that's the
optimal height six four six three six
four yeah but I think six five and
definitely six six you start to look
goofy you know what I mean like it's
it's because then they get long like it
was hard for me to get size because I'm
a height I had to work extra hard on
like working out to get size on me
because my my limbs are long and then
once you get to six six it's just kind
of weird looking you know you're just so
much tired than everybody but if that's
the optimal what downsides have you seen
from yourself yes for yourself
okay I'm curious yeah I fit in my
Lamborghini it's close Okay are there
certain girls that are like no you're
too tall hell no hell no no I've never
that does not happen no in fact
us bro you see it a lot man this is
actually something that people talk
about online a lot is like girls will
put if you're not six foot tall like
swipe left oh they do yeah and I think
that's yeah but that's all on social
media once they meet someone shorter in
person I've seen it firsthand it goes
out the door it's like when they're on
social media Tinder there's so many
options they have to do things to filter
they're going to be like a minimum
there's something on there they're
trying to vet but yeah I think I think
it just depends on on the girl or the
guy in the situation but no I've never
I've never been well I tell you
I've had a lot of people in my life come
to me and say when I first saw you or
met you I hated you but after I got to
know you
I realized I was wrong and so I think
that sometimes I might look like a guy
that used to pick on them in high school
or something and I was the nicest person
on the planet in high school like I was
class favorite like I was at my 10 year
reunion it was one of the best days of
my life because people would come up to
me and they said you were very popular
but you're always nice to me and it
means a lot and it was just like one of
the best days I've ever had in my life
because it was very fulfilling to hear
that you know 10 years later but I have
had people judge me based off of my
appearance
and come to find out later it wasn't
positive I mean I think my height was
probably included in that I definitely
think like from seeing you online and
also seeing you in person you are a bit
intimidating I would say based off of
your stature based off the muscles and
also based off of like just the way that
you walk and the way that you show
yourself I've been told that a lot and
on top of that your stare is very like
when you look at me your eyebrows they
Furrow and they kind of sit low on my
forehead and you're like like lazy very
serious very serious it's just an
intense look which I personally I don't
have a problem with but I'm trying to
understand is that something that you
learned over time like through business
you had to have this intense eye contact
or have you always had this level of
focus well it was probably construction
probably Amplified it and then also
[Music]
um
I do think it's very important to like
let people know that you're truly like I
think you can shake a man's hand and
look him dead in the eyes and he'll know
if you're a snake or not because if you
can't look them dead in the eyes how can
he trust you in my 20s when I'm shaking
some 55 year old white guy's hand and
telling him I'm gonna hit his schedule
and I had to do that to be able to get a
contract for a metal building or to hang
these steel jobs
um yeah it's probably something that I
acquired just out of necessity because I
was the youngest guy in the room and I
was lucky because I was tall because I
looked like a grown ass man you know
coming coming because I play college
football
and so I came into my business man I was
you know six four two forty you know six
three six four I'm a little over six
three barefoot you know like six three
and a half Barefoot and um and so yeah I
think it was an advantage grow a little
bit of a beard out and just little
people dead in the eye especially in the
construction meetings because every
Tuesday in commercial construction you
you know have a subcontractor meeting I
was very often the youngest guy in the
room
and so I had to use kind of a quiet
disposition in body language to be able
to set the tone with basically a room
full of men that are older than me been
doing it for longer than I've been alive
on top of being in shape what would you
say are the next things that guy should
put high up on there I would say value
tier list so it's like getting in shape
would be like s tier top tier like I'll
put these two next to one another
actually
is it really important but your
financial education
huge obviously like guys like you I
agree with that you know and then
understanding female nature truly
understanding it understanding hypergamy
understanding frame explain hypergamy
sure so hypergamy is is kind of like an
evolutionary theory that women will
monkey branch
socioeconomically across or up only and
that if they're in a position where they
could monkey Branch up
is most often the time they would leave
you I want to be very clear that I'm not
talking about how to pick up a woman
I'm not talking about how to like hey
girl what's up how to text I'm not
talking about any of that I'm saying
understanding female nature and
understanding frame with a woman I think
is very important I think
that as much as people want to promote
bad culture
that a strong
stoic
not very emotional understands what he
wants is very direct takes the lead
opens the doors takes the male role
fully
and a man that understands why that's so
important
is a man that has a really good
opportunity a really good shot at having
a long-term relationship I believe that
when a woman loses respect for you she
stops loving you and why would she lose
respect for you like what would cause
maybe you're emotional
maybe you don't provide
in the way that you should maybe because
you don't provide
she is having to go take on a masculine
role out in society
possibly even working for another man
and now I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with a woman in the workplace
clearly you know how I feel about it but
I think you need to have a strong
understanding of
a woman in her actual true nature not
the agenda that's going on right now but
a woman's true nature I think a woman
that is not influenced by bad
culture
or by
promiscuous culture Etc
most often most times and even the girls
that are
strikingly beautiful that make a whole
bunch of money I think ultimately they'd
like to find a man that they can look up
to
that they can submit to is unpopular as
that might be
that they can support on his mission and
be a support system to that mission
and
they would like a man that would be a
leader to them and I think ultimately
they would like to be a wife and I think
they'd like to raise children I don't
believe
that a huge majority of women want to
have these crazy careers I think there's
a lack of good men out there and they
have no choice even the only fans girls
one thing that I'm getting kind of stuck
on out of all of that stuff would be the
emotionless thing not emotionless or
okay sure maybe not emotionless but not
super emotional right but not super yeah
so for example
if a woman knows
that she can upset you easily and that
you're gonna show emotion and act like a
child
I believe there should be a bit of
dissonance between a man and woman not
that men are better but he should be she
should look up to him in some way
respect respect right if she can do the
smallest thing
and bring him down to almost a child
level where they're going to argue on
argue with girls ever so what do you do
if you get in a disagreement with
someone that you're with then we can sit
need a knee and have an adult
conversation
but um there's going to be no yelling so
what's the just so what's the difference
between that and argument it's an
argument a guy that punches a hole in a
wall okay a guy that slams a door
you know a God that can't sit and be
with her
you know I I
if I'm with a girl
I look at it as my job to be
her emotional stable Outlet
I say I've said on many podcasts I
believe a man's job is to be the
mountain that a woman's emotional waves
crash into women are more emotional than
men and when men start acting very
emotional
in a lot of ways I believe he's telling
that woman that he can't emotionally
handle the situation and then she loses
respect
look if he has a hard time at work
or something's going wrong or he takes a
loss I don't think she's going to leave
him but I think if he if he acts like a
child and very very emotional I think
she'll start to get nervous and panic
because obviously he cannot handle the
situation I do think it's very important
for a man to be stoic am I saying that a
man can't have feelings no I'm not
no I'm not I'm not saying that
what I am saying is that he should be
the strong one I believe that the
genders are different
they're equal in different ways and what
loads
their value are completely different
things and I think that's completely
okay and I know that if there are more
strong men out there then women could
allow themselves to let go and be more
effeminine and that's why I really quite
enjoy
helping young men become strong in every
way what about the hypergamy aspect
because it does seem like there is this
narrative that women are just gonna up
and leave as soon as they could find
something better I don't think that's
always true okay but I do think frame is
very important
like you like very non-popular thing for
me I've said in the past is that my girl
doesn't go on girls trips
you know I'm not letting my girl go to
Vegas and get drunk with a bunch of
girls in a club and there's a bunch of
dudes buying models all around them why
would I put her in that position so we
had the same uh conversation with fresh
and Fit I said if my fiance wants to go
they're friends it's a birthday party
and it's at a club it's a girl saying I
wouldn't be bothered by it I think it
really depends on the situation and the
intentions if it's like hey a random
Friday night and it's like a recurring
thing all the time it's like oh but
you're not invited but there's gonna be
other guys but you can't then you you
kind of feel that there's something
maybe up but I think there's so many
innocent times where it's like hey just
going out and having a good time yeah
cool man I mean I I think it's Different
Different Strokes for different people
and I understand where you're coming
from and I don't think that you're wrong
for me it's a no-go did you know what
I've noticed
and I put hard lines in with a woman
particularly around even something like
that I found it to get really turned on
by it
it's the weirdest thing but I think it's
the protective
part that you're showing and I think a
lot of women want to be accounted for to
me it seems like they want to be desired
and by you doing that or saying those
things or putting that boundary it to me
conveys that you're valuing them and you
don't want to lose them and you want to
protect it and you're going to
aggressively protect it and that's the
other part about to me it's just very
Primal it's like the fighting thing
doesn't seem like quite like protecting
it's more so like I really value and
they're very desired to you right very
wanted right that I guess is the way and
so
in that particular scenario if a woman
is just flat out saying no I'm going no
matter what she's going to put on her
sexiest dress
she's gonna put on a push-up bra she can
go out
and she's gonna look better that night
then she probably looked all week at
your house
around other men probably because
women's attention is currency if you
really understand women's nature they
like attention they do that's okay
but for
a woman
to go out dress up have her boobs out
have her heels on have her legs showing
in a club full of men that
are nowhere near me
it's no go for me but how is that
different from an eye I'll give you
another brand a nice watch driving a
nice car in shape yeah well fitted
clothes walking outside go to the mall
and just why is he doing that is that to
impress other guys is that probably all
of the probably all of the above but I
think there's a better example of this
women that put a lot like bikini photos
on Instagram if you're with a special
dude if you're married
and you have your titties out on
Instagram that's a no-go and I feel like
men mess up with the frame part of that
um
because if you're if you're putting
yourself online in that way you are
trying to Garner attention
in some way
and you're trying to get that attention
outside your husband
and so I can tell you that is something
I absolutely wouldn't put up with either
and it's it's all kinds of things
there's all kinds of different ways I
feel like a man can get with Byron or
walk or even my would call a test
from a woman you know but uh being
friends with your ex
guy friends in general
there's not a guy friend that exists
that doesn't want to sleep with a woman
I can't it in if it were the case then
why don't guys have fat girlfriends they
generally don't you don't see do you
have you know a guy that has a friend
that's a girl is obese I don't
and if the opportunity was presented to
that man he would sleep with her
thousand percent of the time God's play
friend zone game all the time so I don't
put up with any girl that I'm seeing
see X's are guy friends I still don't do
it your logic is to protect the woman
you will draw these lines in the sand
yeah establish these boundaries in order
to protect the woman or to protect the
relationship well the relationship
you know I mean I I mean outside of
thinking she's going to get mugged I
mean the very obvious thing is a
relationship
and it doesn't mean I don't trust her
Andrew is very famous for saying I trust
the I trust the locks on my Lamborghini
but I don't park it in the hood I trust
my girl but I ain't gonna put her in a
club in Vegas but see I would have also
confidence in her let's say eight
friends that she's going out with that
they're all going to be looking over
each other assuming that you know the
trend group you're bro
one of those girls wants dick bad one of
those girls maybe two out of the eight
are definitely willing to cheat and
that's an energy just like the one we
talked about with the hiring process
I'm telling you girls night wild wine
titties out everybody's looking good no
bro I'm not doing it this is so far
outside what I'm curious is here's an
argument that I heard that actually
sounds really great
um which was
if you can't be the man where she will
always independent of every other
variable pick you over every other
person that exists on this planet
then why is it in your best interest to
continue to be with her
if you have two Perfect People
that are independent in their own regard
they're making good money they are fully
self-sufficient doing their own thing
and they choose to be with each other
even though they're perfect on their own
that is a relationship that is not based
off of any needs it's not based off of
hey like you know I'll push and pull
give get it's just based off I like you
or I I love you for who you are and
nothing more nothing less let's be
together cool and I and I would follow
up to that and say
in 2023 that is the archetype of what a
couple should be do you agree
like people are trying to be two
individuals that's one of them yeah I
think it's a very popular one and it
don't work
the divorce rates are higher than
they've ever been
there's more single people and if you
follow Rolo at all he said by I think
it's like by 2040 like half of the women
will be childless and not married
it doesn't work no I do want to say the
divorce rates because that was something
I I've looked into in the past right and
I even go so far as to be like
statistically what has the highest
divorce rates usually it's marrying
young but it's also what what raises it
to the 50 percent is the second third
fourth marriages which have like an 80
failure rate from what I've seen people
who have an education who make a certain
amount of money I think it was more than
like 80 000 a year who marry above the
age of 25 I think the divorce rate was
more like 25 30 it's still high yeah but
still less than the 50 when you account
for all these other variables now the
other thing is that maybe they haven't
been married long enough to see the
divorce but they are marrying later with
a lower divorce rate so far from what
we've seen either way
I do believe in generals and
I don't believe in suppressing a person
but also believe in not setting them up
to be put in a bad position
that's all because hey let's just meet
for coffee
can turn into many things very quickly
especially if a man knows what he's
doing but see part of me believes that
like if that happens I would be so glad
in a way because I like I never cheated
on because I would know without a shadow
of a doubt that's not the person for me
without I would have had no doubts in my
mind to be able to walk away
very clearly like that to me seems like
I would rather just that happen and move
on right and I would seem like a bit of
a relief in a sense okay now I know
there we go you know and if she would be
happier by all means like obviously I'd
be upset but to me that would just be a
clear signal that hey this wasn't meant
to be yeah I get it I got a message from
a guy today he told me
said hey man
um my ex cheated with her ex-boyfriend
I got a DNA test but she is pregnant
with my child
bro
how do you move forward in that he goes
from hey I'm gonna meet I'll meet Kevin
to
I cheated on you I don't even know if
this your kid it's just man there's
certain lies I also feel like there's
got to be red flags
and they're in their micro things like
Instagram posts or
girls trips are
there's a multitude of different things
it could be you know guy friends are
going to lunch with dudes like there's
no way and listen I'm not trying to be
this chauvinistic
I just believe that if you're firm in
these things women respect it I guess I
take the approach if someone's gonna
cheat they're gonna cheat regardless if
you say you can't go to the club they're
gonna find a way around it if that's the
objective I think if a girl really I
think of a girl really really loves you
she don't want to go anyway I agree but
I don't want to go anywhere but I think
there's also
self-esteem issues I think there could
be issues in the relationship itself
where she doesn't feel like she's gonna
now I'm not saying this is justification
but I could see issues in a relationship
that would prompt somebody to want to go
and cheat and that type of person who
would go and cheat instead of resolving
those issues I don't think it's a person
that I'd ever want to be involved with
so it just seems like to me that's a
filter unfortunately you have to go
through the hard way figuring out hey
this is not what I want to be involved
in this person is not for me I would
also add to what you just said by saying
women generally don't want space until
they already have a foot out the door
and so that would be something to
consider as well just knowing what it
looks like you know
so that's my thoughts on it it's been
really good to me man you'd be shocked
you could sit down with a girl and when
she sits down
she's damn near liberal or or bad
all the way
and by the time
I'll leave the date she's very
traditional I've watched girls fall into
the feminine frame right in front of me
many many times a lot of women message
me even now and they say look I've
watched you on podcasts and you've
really helped me get in my feminine
frame you've made me a better wife I get
a bunch of messages from women like that
or asking me for advice because they're
madly in love with their husband and
he's maybe screwing up
and like what can I do to wake him up I
really love him and believe in them I
think those are the best women ever as
long as they're not indirectly trying to
hit how are they screwing up like in
what sense I'm just curious I got one
today man it's uh
God has an addiction problem you know
and she she really loves him and she
really believes in them and he told her
that if they were to have a child he
thinks they would turn around and I told
her that that's not true that having a
child is not going to change his ways
then I went into fitness and I wrote her
a couple paragraphs and then I sent her
a voice memo about why I thought it was
important that he gets sober get in
shape so he can have a clear mind he
probably does want to do better for you
he probably does want to have a family
with you but unless he gets sobered up a
bit and gets into some kind of good
physical condition he'll never have the
energy to do so you know and so
um I get messages like that quite a bit
and a lot of women just thank me for
almost giving them permission to be what
they already are you know and you know I
think each relationship has its own
rules and structures I can tell you mine
do and they're not they're traditional
and non-traditional in a lot of ways but
there's no mistakes about who the leader
is and where the frame is see I tend to
also think that people show themselves
very early and that you could learn a
lot about a person really from the first
like few dates whether or not they're
present with you if they're on their
phones just like with your employees if
they go and gossip about other people
but but those are all red flags that yep
I think unfortunately because people
don't pay attention to they don't care
maybe the other person's hot and they're
just like you know I'll put up with more
but you know all this stuff because hey
you know what they're good looking but
you know what else I'd argue sure you
take the same woman
you've heard a man a and she'll act one
way
you give her to man B and she'll act a
completely other way women don't text on
dates when I'm with them but I bet they
text on other dates if they're not
interested and that's why becoming the
best type of man you can is so important
so if you take religion out of this
let's just take religion out of it for a
second
who is she gonna respect more
some guy that's working valet at the
hotel I'm at or Graham Stefan let's say
y'all are equally attractive sure
she's like man this dude's got his
together he's got this this
together has anything to do with it oh
bro no I have status status money you're
not fat so so like all these different
levels of being a god a thousand percent
I've had completely different
experiences in my early 20s go on dates
I I was driving a Lotus I had houses I
was you know working a good real estate
job they would much rather the dude
who's having a fun time with his buddies
Carefree is you know sleeps on his his
friends what age is that what age early
20s right so they call it they call it
the whole phase right sure so Rolo has a
book called the rational mail I believe
he covers it there so he's like from 18
to 27 is what he calls the hoe phase
from 28 to like 35 I guess is The
Epiphany phase it's the oh I better
have babies soon I gotta start taking
this serious so you were dating girls in
that phase girls were leaving you to
have sex with athletes in Chads and
jocks and bad boys and all those other
things
um
but
All Things Considered let's say a 33
year old woman
goes on a date with you and goes on a
guy that looks just like you and your
Graham Stefan and he's not I'm telling
you right now she's putting that phone
away
because it's about the man you become
yeah the world treats you differently so
what if you're what if you're on a date
with a woman in that phase which phase
explain it which phase you talking about
like an 18 year old
like
I'm 24. cool it's the woman I'm dating
are within that age range I got a hack
for you you just provided here's the
hack okay date women
28 to 40. I would probably those
got snacks bro but I would prefer
they're the best they've been divorced
already crazy sex they don't expect
anything out of you when I was in
college
okay I had some older girlfriends when I
was playing football in college they
were like 30. I thought I was a big boss
Jack wants to date you know what I
should be speaking for you yes thank you
thank you you're welcome
so if I if I'm trying to find my person
right my lifelong partner and I'm dating
women that are in that age range how do
you discern whether or not they're a
subscriber of that ideology right of
that phase or there's someone that's
actually looking for their lifetime
partner or you find someone in that
phase but you try to get them out of
that phase like how do you maybe bring
someone out of the the whole phase if I
were 24
I would not even be looking for a long
time partner until I was at least 28 and
I feel like 28 is pretty young because
look at it for what it is you most women
marry a man between six and seven years
older than them already off the rip so
that means you had to go down to like 18
right the problem is she has to get from
18 to like 28.
she's gonna have certain feelings and
want to do certain things in her life
and trying to
force her not to or or like it's it's it
is set up for failure and that goes
right in line with what you said about
people getting married past 25. if I
were you
genuinely I would do nothing but get
jacked get your money up you're already
handsome this is to stop man bro
you you're you can't even
fight I slap the out of you right
now right now stop the out of you
but but just take this outside no
problem but the point I'm making is is
girls your age
want me in my age
most often
we've built everything in our life I
mean women get their value
right off the top for free right out the
gate they need to try their best to not
be promiscuous
so a higher value men later would take
them seriously and people ain't gonna
like that but I don't care men don't
want women look at what's happening with
what is it Logan Paul right now
everybody's making fun of him because
his girlfriend everybody yeah but
I don't believe I don't I don't either I
don't either I don't either but I'm just
giving you an example of the perception
of that right I actually have no idea
and don't care yeah but
if I were you I would put my head down
and get so
deeply ingrained in Fitness a go box
business everything that y'all are doing
and build your money and build yourself
as a man because I'll tell you what's
going to happen it's probably already
happening to you because
you're good looking and and you're
doing things women are just going to
jump in front of you so I truly believe
women bet on horses they look down at
the field and they're like which one of
these guys are going to win
and some girls are oftentimes good girls
especially because your work work work
work work they're just gonna jump in
front of you and you're just gonna run
them over and you might end up having I
had a girlfriend for like five or six
years in my 20s she's a bit crazy and I
and I told her that I was gonna have
other girlfriends and she acted like I
didn't say it so I did it and she'd get
mad and just back and forth but uh you
know I was around her a lot
and um
if I were you man I truly mean this I
wouldn't even be looking for a wife
right now there's so much you have to do
yeah and those guys that get married
early they never achieve what they
should have achieved and it doesn't work
because he never becomes a man that he
could have well I'll say from my own
experience I didn't truly come into
myself until I was probably 28. yeah
really I was just so much I was told
when I was 18. I started working in real
estate and I was told people are not
really going to take you seriously until
you're 25. and like 25 is when it starts
to happen because it starts to level out
in terms of your mature it's like a
mental thing about that age too yeah I
think it was just relating to other
people in such a way that you you
couldn't do before the age of 25 because
you haven't had the experience but even
me at 25 like I was insecure I would
overthink everything I wasn't sure of
myself you didn't have enough experience
no I didn't and you and you're going to
need a lot of experience with women
you're gonna need to see how they act
you know you're gonna need to go through
relationships
sleep with someone I mean I'm not saying
you're not doing that but you know like
experience the different parts of the
relationships with the girls I just
wouldn't want to see you get your heart
in and I'll tell you another thing a guy
like you particularly I'm not trying to
be your Mentor right now but I'm just
using you for anything go ahead a guy
like you that's ambitious that's going
to do a lot of good stuff
you might settle for a girl based off
the man you are today when you're going
way up here
and then that's going to create a whole
nother problem for you because the girl
you can really get at your maturity
let's say between 33 and 35 it's
probably going to be substantially
better material probably more beautiful
probably a lot of things better than
what you can get today
and I just believe that to be true and
do you believe though that there's value
in having someone come up with you and
building that shared thing not
necessarily I think that's a bit more of
a pipe dream my parents met in high
school my dad was a senior my mom I
think was like a junior in the 70s or
the 80s bro 80s yeah all right Jackson
hey I I don't really have any rebuttal
to that that's not this water yeah go
for it thanks bro I don't drink water
it's just coffee he's he's insane
horrible
he doesn't drink water I I kid you not
he drinks no water I do in the protein
shake okay just a protein shake Optimum
Nutrition I don't know how easy bro it's
coffee's water here's the thing about
your parents man
in the 80s your dad might see one woman
every now and then in a Walmart parking
lot that's beautiful he can live in the
same town with her for the next 20 years
and might not see her again right but
now yeah yeah it's over it's over bro
and
on a daily basis you're going to be
getting compared to other men so a
couple of comments uh about this whole
conversation so being in the dating pool
I've noticed certain girls look for
certain things not every girl is in that
phase some girls are not some girls
clearly aren't based off of the evidence
or my own personal experiences and stuff
like that
um I would say
laugh everybody's a little bit different
Different Strokes for different folks
there is this phase yes that does exist
I have seen it uh but also there are
definitely other people that are
candidates that are good open-minded
people and I do think that there is some
Merit in growing up with this person
because you don't necessarily want
somebody to like you just based off of
external factors such as how much money
you have right I think that's such a
small component in terms of money
because there's always going to be
someone else with more money always yeah
I think I think more internal values
such as are you an honest person right
are you punctual uh can you rely on this
person stuff like that are better and
stronger foundations to build relation
successful relationships off of rather
than other things that sure could be
indicators of those traits but such as
wealth such as
I don't know maybe like fancy shoes and
stuff like that you know on a scale of
one to a hundreds what percentage based
off of where you believe you're gonna
land as a man do you feel like you're
already developed I mean that's funny
because when I when I was like 19 I
thought I was at like 70. and I was just
thinking about this a couple weeks just
like a 19 year old yeah uh I
hope low uh I hope I'm at 30. uh maybe
20. but realistically I would say I'm at
maybe 40 and there's a bunch of things
that you don't know that you don't know
yet myself included I think it's best
for a man to try to develop and really
get a grip on his life who he is what he
wants
because well all I want for anybody that
either watches my content whether that's
my kid or for somebody I love or a
friend is for them to have choice
you know and there's a lot of developing
to do before you can even get to a place
where you actually know what you want in
the first place and what that looks like
for you you're going to change a lot in
the next five years I agree
astronomically
and what might look good to you today
might look horrible in five years and so
if you were married
it could it doesn't really set you up
for success and I think that's why the
the failure rate is so high now if you
were 35 and she was 25.
then maybe
you know you're in the ballpark but I
wouldn't do until I was in my 30s for
sure I think some of it is coming into
who you are knowing who you are yeah a
thousand percent self I think makes you
attractive to more people so that you
have more options to pick from but it's
not coming from a place of scarcity it's
really like you know I want to be with
you not because you're the only option
but because we get along together but
people can also fall for that at 19 when
he thought he was 100 there and his
chest was poked out he can talk like a
very confident man who knows what he
wants he sounds decisive he didn't know
it all and neither did I and I can tell
you right now I'm still developing as a
person I don't even know what percentage
I am
I I hope it's
less than 70 for damn sure hope it's 60.
I hope I have a lot of growth left in me
um
but
you at 24. man
you're going to do so many things and
you're going to grow so much I from 24
to 30 for me
huge deal from 30 to 35 it's probably
10x that let me ask you objectively I'm
33. what growth did you see between 30
and 35. stress
tolerance
the businesses were growing I got down a
million bucks one time I should have
went bankrupt
um
I started to see what was important to
me I made big money for the first time
and bought things and did things
and really got to experience like full
cycle like my Lamborghini is cool
I wouldn't trade it for my Ford and it
doesn't make my life
it doesn't make me happy growing makes
me feel happy so I have to learn these
things about myself where are my
weaknesses
how can I fill in those weaknesses you
know everybody has weaknesses the more
you understand yourself the better you
can build the castle around you right
because I don't want to hire another
person like me I'm me I need people to
cover my blind spots where am I not
confident what do I don't know that I
don't know
you know what mentors can I build and
learn from how do I want to align with
the values of other people
and do I feel confident in my values it
takes a lot of confidence for me to come
on the internet and say some of the
things I say knowing the amount of hate
I'm gonna get for it but I know who I am
and I'm okay with that because my real
life is so good there's nothing anybody
could ever say to me on the internet
that would make me even look twice they
can call me whatever they want my life
is incredible I am genuinely happy and
it took a lot of pain to get there and
took a lot of understanding of myself
and it took a lot of even forgiving
myself on things that I might not be as
skilled at or disciplined at and so I
set up structures to make up for those
things because ultimately I want to win
I want to have choice I want to be an
honest person I definitely want to be
myself because if I can't be myself I
can't even respect myself when I'm being
something fake to somebody else just so
they'll like me I'm one thing away from
them not liking me anyway so them
if you ever lost a job because someone
sees you online they see the company
that you work with and say I don't want
to do anything to do with this guy yeah
I've had that happen with you know
Andrew
I have but I don't give a down
because for every person that hates me I
feel like I get 100x people that love me
for who I actually am yeah someone
loving you for who you actually are is a
lot more powerful than 100 one person is
hating you yeah
like yeah more than 10 people who like
love you for maybe who they believe you
are but it's not actually who you are
right and those people don't even
actually know me case in point the whole
phone call we had about me coming on
here and the risk it is to you
I respect that I really do I don't have
a problem with it at all I'm just glad I
got the opportunity for you to get to
know who I am I'm sure there'll be a
negative comment
on the video if you post it
and if you don't then I've still enjoy
the hell about spending time with you
guys and I've been wanting to meet you
for a while so it's good to me but
there's no way I can walk out of here
and not know that I gave you myself
and as long as I give myself to you
whether you like it or not I was true to
myself
and
I believe that
if there's what eight billion people on
the planet
bro if I can have two billion people
love me for who I actually am
other 6 billion could hate my
guts
because it's very rare that you have
that many people or any amount of people
actually love you for you you actually
are
and I sleep with no skeletons in my
closet and it's a very free feeling for
me
and I'm able to tell people the truth
all the way there's a lot of people that
live a life where they can't even be
their full self because they're too
scared about what other people are going
to think of them I can tell you not
having that feeling is like having a
load taken off of you like nothing else
and a lot of people believe that there's
nobody out there that'll love them for
who they are
for whatever reason and it's just not
true the good thing about 2023 is that
you can go find a group of people that
believe in in what you believe that
you're kind of like your souls align
with
and once you have just a small group of
people
that love you in that way for exactly
who you are
everything else would just be noise and
I'm very lucky in that way and I have
genuine happiness because of it because
I don't have to lie to anybody
no and I'm very grateful for that I feel
very lucky and very blessed to have that
in my life and I had to get to that
and it took me about 34 years to do it
what pushed you over the edge of getting
to that
what happened at 34 where pushed you
over the edge a little bit I really
struggled with guilt
all throughout my teens and 20s
I felt like I had to come out of the
closet and tell everybody that I was not
gay
but I really liked women and I didn't
particularly ever believe in you know a
man like me being monogamous I just
didn't and I was so scared that people
are going to hate me so much for it
and people do hate me for it
my issue with that is that if I were to
tell you that I'm gay
I would be automatically protected
but if I tell you hey coming out the
closet I'm super straight I like women
I'm gonna tell them all the truth but
I'm gonna have a bunch of girlfriends
and a wife and a family and all this
other stuff people hate you for
it
but so many men have a wife and a family
and they're watching PornHub every night
or they're slipping around with their
secretary
if I'm nothing I'm honest and I give
people the opportunity to leave if they
want to
choice
the only thing I want for myself for my
kids for my friends for my family and
particularly the people I love
and so if they choose to stay with me
after I've told them the truth
or they choose to be with me when I tell
them the truth I'm not a bad guy
now it might piss people off but again
if I were homosexual
I would be celebrated I'd be a hero
but if I tell the truth about my sexual
preference I don't have sexual
discipline
it's crazy what do you say to people
that say that that you could be more
disciplined and just like you were about
sexual things yes yeah cool not being
awesome yeah I get it if there's a pizza
sitting on this table right now
and you were on a diet
and I wasn't and my preference was to
eat pizza
but I still have a six-pack
is it discipline
or do I know how to intermittent fast do
I know how to
have what I want in life
it's a preference I'm not insecure I
don't need attention from I like it so
you're saying because it's not hurting
anybody it's not hurting your wife it's
not hurting your girlfriends they're all
fine with it right there's no sacrifice
that you're actually making aside from
these other people's perceptions that
you may not even care about in the first
place first of all my wife helps she's a
fan we bring girls around
you know oh and oh and by the way before
everybody starts hating on me go get a
man by himself and be like yo bro
if your wife said that you could bring a
smoking hot 22 year old blonde over and
y'all could both do it
would you do it if he tells you no he's
a liar you know it's a liar okay
I don't know man I mean I will say that
I I don't I couldn't do it I'm I'm like
one person I just
bro in the 90 percentile
90. let's say he says no bro what
percentage of men watch porn
is a high percentage you think it's all
those guys oh no I think it's almost
every man almost every man are you
telling me if you had a girlfriend she
was like Hey I want to bring Shelly over
we won't want to have sex with you you
would be like no I don't know it's never
happened well you need to have a
threesome and you need to get in a fight
let me you know what's actually really
funny uh so
I was talking to this girl can I just
say something I'm so sorry I don't mean
to cut you off yeah yeah
that doesn't make you a man
sleeping with a bunch of women doesn't
make you a man what makes you a man is
that you know who you are
you stand behind what you believe
you don't
put on a mask or tell people what they
want to hear so they like you
and you do what you say you're gonna do
and you're loyal to the people and the
commitments that you've made
you can be ethical
and find the people that will accept you
for who you are arth is also good
qualities that you'd like in a woman too
everything that's most of your time
we're just talking I know but what makes
a man I'm just saying I think it makes I
think it makes a solid I think it makes
a solid person I'll tell you another
thing I don't do and I think it's super
lame when I see people do it they'll
start their comment on YouTube with a
real man would who the are you to
take somebody's man card from them these
people have no photos on their on their
account they're probably fat as I
could be like a real man's in shape a
real man is a millionaire I would never
ever ever
attach or say to somebody they're not a
real man I think that's a dumb ass thing
to say
you know and I don't need the ego boost
of like taking their manhood from them
it's like if I were to tell you you're
not a man because you didn't have a
threesome it'd be the most
asinine thing I could ever say to you or
that you didn't get in a fight so you're
not a man that doesn't mean you're not a
man I don't Define what makes you a man
you do
and so
I think that's I think that's a really
great point I think for a man and a
woman but it's really just a solid
person you know like we're not always
like I can very clearly see that we
don't agree on this subject right
but I've absolutely enjoyed and loved
this conversation and really like you
both you know what I'm saying so like
why do we why would we not be friends
just because
I like to have a couple chicks to the
house like the hell out of here I'll
also never stab you in the background
I'll tell you another thing I'll never
do I'll never look at your wife crooked
or do anything other than say Graham is
a man when you go take a piss
because that's what a real friend does
for me a good friend a loyal friend
you know I'd rather punch myself in the
face and hit on your wife you
know what I mean because if we're
friends and I have no honor
then what am I good for
you know I can be
disciplined as hell on on this subject
you know if I need to be case in point a
friend guys Lose Friends all the time
we've had for 30 years because
they don't have any options in their
life and they get close to that that
girl that that was married to his best
friend and then he ends up sleeping with
her bro
you don't have many friends in this
world my favorite line from any movie in
history is in Tombstone
there's a there's a shootout guy at
stock holiday he's like holy man
why'd you help him he said because he's
my friend and he goes man I got a lot of
friends and doc said I don't that's my
favorite line of any movie ever because
Doc Holliday understood
that in life you're going to have a
handful of friends
anybody that believes they have more
than just a handful probably doesn't
have any at all and that loyalty is
something that like I really pride
myself on having and I've gotten a good
opportunity to take up from my friends
recently and I feel very lucky to be
able to do it being a good person like
you said I think it's almost a bygender
thing you know it's being true to
yourself what are some of the questions
you think the viewer should ask
themselves that could be productive to
observe so I think for example people
should always question their
relationship with finances question
their relationship with money ask
themselves questions about how they feel
about spending money on this versus
spending money on this versus saving and
stuff like that that's a good one ask
themselves questions about their
relationships such as their friendships
why do they value their friends what do
they value in their friends are those
good values period
people that they're dating parents Etc
what are questions you think the viewers
should be asking themselves
I think all of those things that you
just said are incredible
I think that
some of the questions
should be based off of where you are
in your life like every person has a
life cycle every business has a life
cycle every career has a life cycle I
would ask myself
not for competition's sake but maybe how
am I doing in comparison to my peers
what can I do to get ahead
what am I doing on a daily basis to set
myself up to be successful later am I in
the right career path
what is the guy 20 years ahead of me
that does exactly what I do
what is his life like
do I want that life
I think that's one of the biggest ones
you can ask yourself I remember I was
one of the youngest members of the metal
building contractors Directors
Association
and I'm sitting there and everybody's
like 25 years older than me and I'm
looking around at these guys and I asked
myself I said do I want this guy's life
some of them maybe a lot of them have
like heart attacks and construction
very stressful
I was like I'm gonna buy real estate
very quickly
in the second I started making money I
just started buying it
and um the reason I did that is because
I looked at their lives and I said man
no disrespect they're very help helpful
and a lot of them are millionaires
I don't know that I want this life not
for another 25 or 30 years so what do I
want
for me it was freedom
and so I started looking out there for
people that were living a life that I
thought I might want to live
and I think it's very important that
when you're looking at these people
don't make the assumption that you're
special don't make the assumption that
you're going to work harder than them
don't make the assumption that you're
smarter than them because more than
likely you're going to run into the same
punches that they did
and
evaluate their situation do they make
the kind of money you want to make are
they in the right business vehicle
to make that kind of money
do they have the freedom that you
believe you're going to want
you know do they have the stress
you know do they have the relationships
that they want or is we're stressing
them out so much that they bring it home
there's so many things you can learn
about where you're going from the people
that are already doing exactly what you
believe you want to do
and if you just don't think you're
special and you look very closely at all
those layers of it
you could reset your trajectory
long before you're too late because it's
just like you guys know if you tilt a
plane just five ten percent in in New
York City by the time it was supposed to
land in San Diego it lands in San
Francisco my main question
for myself
outside of like my personal Integrity
myself and everything we've talked about
being who you actually want to be
would be
looking at the people that are 20 years
ahead of me and asking myself if I want
their life and for me I didn't and so I
had to make small adjustments how did
you start buying real estate what was
the main focus on that was it purely
just you want cash flow you want to
retire you want something to fall back
on what was the motivation you know it
was really really important to me with
real estate is that
I didn't want to be that guy that made a
bunch of money once
I was actually scared of that I don't
really care that much about the cash
flow at all I really care about the
appreciation
because I'm probably gonna do the whole
buy borrow die thing anyway trust it
um
and so for me
I want to be rich for sure don't be
wealthy wealthy's
you know the difference between being
rich and being wealthy is one of them is
destructible one of them is not actually
Brandon Carter asked me lately do you
have a money goal and I said no the
reason I said no is I really have a
layers goal
I want layer on top of layer on top of
layer on top of layer of income that way
I know that no matter what happens in
any climate any condition anything that
comes up for me I'm impenetrable so
here's what that is like what your
definition of wealth is and what that
income layer is for you well as far as
income goes
[Music]
um
I mean to be quite honest I don't need
to make hundreds of millions of dollars
I probably will on at the rate that I'm
going and I plan to develop more and do
more things because I genuinely like the
game and the Chase and the climb of
business but I think the happiness thing
I think they've done studies on this
it's like
somewhere at like two million dollars a
year
you're not much happier until you get to
like maybe like something stupid like 10
and then that that amount of happiness
is super small Lopez I learned more
about that from Tai Lopez and I have
anyone else he said that you don't want
to be the dude making like 20 30 million
dollars a year because that person's
taken all the hits they're taking all
the criticism they're taking all the
liability it's the people making one to
three that have the best work life
balance they're making enough to pretty
much buy whatever they want but they're
flying under the radar in terms of you
know being a punching bag right taking
on he said that most people were the
happiest in terms of that upper bracket
one to three yeah
so what is it for you last year made
about five
um and you know you know what's very
humbling about that to me I met guys
like Ed Marlette dude has an island you
know what I mean like and I somebody
told me the other day it was a negative
comment they're like they said something
along the lines of like you're not any
effing Elon Musk or Steve Jobs and I
said you know what
you're absolutely right
and I think that it's important for the
young people to really understand this
is that there is such a huge gap between
me
and that person that person let's say
they make
75k a year and I make my 5 million or
whatever I make or 3 million or four or
seven or whatever it is below 10 I might
never never be Steve Jobs
100 million 200 million billionaire
Amazon right
but I can tell you that the Gap and
happiness between me and zoc is probably
pretty small with less pressure but the
gap between me and the person that said
that comment
is Light Years so what is your ideal net
worth or monthly income that you'd like
to strive for like I said uh it's a
layers thing for me
you know
um I'd love to keep making what I'm
making right now sometimes I pitch
myself and I'm like man there's no way I
keep doing this forever you know you
know because the bit one of the one of
my main businesses in this Prime the
steel company and everything we're doing
online it keeps growing and growing and
growing
the real estate portfolio can you share
how that's broken down if you have as
Jax is a pie chart yeah you have your
income how is that broken down between
the businesses I'll make around four in
construction
and I'll make
one to one five on the internet
and then I'm pushing everything back
into the properties because I don't like
the debt
atmosphere right now so I want to drive
as much Equity as we can into the
properties to reduce the impact of debt
service at you know six percent rates or
an eight percent rate and then some
people are holding i o for us there's a
balloon coming up and I want to be very
very Equity strong when that refinance
comes sure now why would you make less
in the construction business because it
seems to me I'll make more I make the
most in construction yes but I'm just
saying like over time over the next 10
years because you're afraid well I'll
tell you I'll tell you seems very stable
outstanding career I'll tell you why
is I don't think construction's brick
and mortar it's not near as explosive as
the internet and it's also very eat what
you kill
I don't think I'll ever start another
business
where I don't get a lifetime return on
investment of energy or at least a very
long one right so let's say you hold a
property for 20 years and maybe you exit
are you hold and borrow against Equity
Insurance Company would be a great
example like I've talked to Ed about
possibly starting an insurance company
myself you know because once you get a
client you're going to have them for
quite a while construction is very much
bid hope you make money one time then
hunt hunt
I don't think I'll start another
business that is one hunt one kill and
then back to hunting ever ever again
seems like you do really well training
people
how to do construction or some sort of
learning some sort of online you know
education company on kind of like gym
launch but for construction yeah because
I don't as far as I'm aware that doesn't
really exist like a network of
contractors people that want to get into
the trades like if I want to be an
electrician I'm sure it exists I'm just
not aware of it I would love a community
of other like-minded electricians that
we could work together grow together you
know if I get a referral I just don't
have the time I can bid it out to
someone else I could refer that if it's
in a different area there's a network of
just bringing people in those people
will be so valuable those people exist
those groups exist they're just in
person okay and they're ran by like 60
year old white men I mean it seems like
to me that's your perfect well I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why is because
there's a lot there's a lot of growing
pains in construction and then also
right now as for now
Andrew and I made a deal
that we would work together on what
we're working on
and so I'm not going to go back on that
deal
you know he's been really good to me
we're Team
and that's how I look at it so it's very
easy decision for me not to do it I get
asked to do it all the time and I do
think I'd make a ton of money
but there's other ways to make other
businesses and one thing that I really
like about the social media thing is
that
I'm acquiring very very good talent
and what I love about having a brand is
it creates a whole different
relationship from the start of working
with somebody previously in my old life
if somebody came and worked for me it
was very much kind of a
I almost say mercenary completely
different from the people that want to
come work for me now because they know
who I am they know what I'm about they
they all it's like they already have the
core values
they already want to jump in and bang
and row the boat and take it places
they already actually like the guy
they're working for
which is a very uncommon situation in
this world
and so if I can keep a choir and talent
off the internet
if I can continue to buy properties
if I can continue to work with people I
care about and there's a purpose and a
mission behind it you know you know
what's so crazy to me is that
I get stopped like 20 30 times a day for
photos now which is very new to me
but what I've noticed about it is
instead of saying hey
like like an athlete or an actor hey I
saw you on the show or hey you know I
see that you play for the Dodgers
they're stopping to tell me you changed
my life
what you say matters
and I enjoy being a part of that
movement
and me and Andrew have done a lot of
that together it's very fulfilling to me
and so for now
until
either things change or they never will
who knows or we do something else I
quite enjoy it and the money ain't bad
but more importantly
I'm really helping people and unlike
real estate and construction when you
hit a schedule you give somebody a roof
to put over their head the people that
I'm helping now actually genuinely
appreciate it
in construction no news is good news
in real estate
in real estate not having a big rent
roll of people that haven't paid you
or is good news so no news is good news
in those businesses
and so when it comes to online or
teaching people how to be a contractor
um
I just don't feel like it's time and it
might never be time sure it's funny
anytime the property manager calls me
you're like because I know something's
broken like automatically and they could
automatically fix things I think it's up
until like 500 bucks so I know
automatically it's more than 500 yeah
they call me it's dare but it's an awful
feeling bro okay so we just bought this
mobile home park man
and I guess the old owner would let
people pay like on the 25th of the month
and they're just constantly a month late
I see a rent roll this morning of like
it was like 16 Grand that we have not
collected now we're still cash flowing
yeah but we should have been cash
flowing 22 Grand where where was the
property it's in Louisiana it's in
Louisiana yeah yeah but it's just
you know people have to get used to the
new management the new systems you know
I've noticed they have like older
landlords they don't care as much
especially they don't because they're
always there they're cutting the grass
the property's paid off oh yeah there's
less of a concern they value the Peace
of Mind than collecting a little extra
yeah or making them do it on time sure
he doesn't he doesn't want it
he owns an electrical company really
cool dude I really like him a lot um
really really smart man you really
turned that park around it's really nice
he so really it was a really in my
opinion like a very fair exchange he
like tripled his money over tripled his
money but it's still a strong cap rate
it's still good after Debt Service
bro it was like it's got to be bro it's
removal it bro it's like 12 yeah yeah
and The Debt Service on it is
like 16 but if if we get it 95 and
everybody pays rent on time with cash
flow 20 22 Grand a month you know it's
worth it now the balloon would come up
you know because he's doing IO for us so
we have to go into traditional financing
but
um I'm actually super hoping in the next
couple years kind of goes the other way
I don't think it could go very much
higher now I think it could kind of get
staggy you want interest you mean
interest rates to go down I'd love to
see them go down yeah I think everybody
would yeah and I don't know but even if
it doesn't yeah even if it doesn't these
properties I think people make a big
mistake by looking at cap rate
I don't I don't I mean cap rate's great
cool you know how the property performs
but I think a big mistake that you can
make is not understanding Debt Service
and like understanding where the debts
go and when it's going to balloon even
in the cycle even in the long like if
like you ever watch the ray dalio video
long term short-term debt cycle yes kind
of like understanding where you are in
that long-term short-term debt style
debt cycle in regards to whether it's a
five year or 15 or a seven year whatever
the balloon is like even now I'm gonna
constantly be shopping debt
you know it's just something I want to
do and then insurance is just just
everything about it so um
yeah it's a the only thing that's
nerve-wracking for me is Debt Service
really because cap rate's cap rate if
you're not emotional
you know yeah and
we're always going to be raising the
rents isn't that risky though that Indie
event interest rates end up going up
five years isn't that always the risk
not if you lock in if you lock in now
then your biggest risk is not
maintaining a property or having the
area deteriorating value yeah are you
getting
how long has it been since you bought a
commercial property never bought
commercial and so this is commercial
yeah so I can't get this fixed right
30-year you know maybe you could still
fix Seven Ten Years yeah that's what I
just said though yeah and so it's like
okay where are we in seven years you
know where are we in three years because
some of my balloons come up in three now
the good news about the ones that come
up in three
is we have extension options on them to
extend where they make more money we try
to offer like a couple different offers
well I think I think the difference here
is that you're doing it seems like
interest-only balloon payments yeah they
are which so it's lower money up front
more cash flow up front way risk of five
years from now what happens when that
resets versus doing you know yeah I get
that or you know something for 10 years
and it the interest rate could could
bump up a percentage based on yes sir
but it's certainly better than taking
an eight percent interest rate from the
bank
right now because I believe
if I had to bet now I'm not super
bullish on this
I think after the election
and I don't think it's going to be a lot
just a little bit like a point or two
but that point or two is huge people
don't understand how one point is to a
property one percentage point
and to lock that in like to it's a I
think it's been analysis I think one
percentage point equates on average it's
between eight to twelve percent of the
properties value yeah which is crazy
yeah so a million dollars one percent
all of a sudden it's a hundred grand off
one thing that I'm making for certain
that I'm doing is that I have no
refinance penalties
and um that makes me feel good because I
do believe through and I'm also telling
the banks like listen you're giving me
this loan you're not giving me a penalty
I want to refinance with you just give
me the going rate what's out there right
now so we'll see what I'm very excited
about the cash flow
um there's definitely work to be done
there's some cap like I bought 64
apartments in December and there's
definitely capex the mobile home parks
that we have in Ohio are are doing well
and I feel good about that and it's
really just about getting all the
systems all the way in yeah and uh
getting the plane off the ground here's
an interesting question because you grew
up in a in a trailer park right yeah I
lived in four on it so I lived in them
on and off yeah what is that like for
you owning a trailer park having grown
up in one there's a country music song
called I'm gonna be somebody someday
uh one of the first things I did was get
in my truck
and drive through that Park listening to
that song
you heard it no oh yeah you should you
should it was it was good for my soul
man it was everything I ever dreamed of
like I always dreamed of
you know
making enough money where I could buy
real estate I own the neighborhood bro I
own all of it there's 60 trailers in
there
I see all those mailboxes
I own this place it's not even about the
money yeah you know I'm not even
pocketing the money
it it's about the achievement you know
to me and the fact that I know that I'm
taking care of my future in such a solid
way with such a solid asset you can
touch it
now plenty of crypto but I'm not I'm not
as proud of my cryptos I am my real
estate yeah because it was always my
goal you know before YouTube got big
real estate was like Bigger Pockets you
watched your stuff
uh
it was the only it was the only thing I
knew and people forget this we talk
about subscription-based models that
real estate is the OG of the
subscription-based model it's like the
OG
and I don't even meet many people in the
self-development space or people that
want to get better that don't say they
want to own real estate I actually did
it it means ever it means so much to me
and it's completely not monetary you
ever see kids in the trailer park and
think you know that was me at one point
and want to help them out I have that
moment yeah I have that moment
um
I don't really think like I'm open to
helping them I have the I remember that
you know and also have the thought like
they can get out of here
you know and it's up to them to realize
that or not they were to come up to me
and ask me
um which one thing that I haven't
experienced yet is that one of my
tenants know me
you know with a lot of people that know
me now
um I'm sure it's gonna happen
and I can't wait to unload onto that um
because it's probably gonna be a young
man right I can't wait to sit him down
and tell them I'll sit right there on
that porch with them and tell them they
can do it because I believe it
because I've seen it all lived it and um
and I know it's true it doesn't matter
where you come from or what it is like
you if you can flip it into a strength
somehow that it makes you stronger then
you can achieve anything you want how do
you think that made you stronger like
what was life like growing up in a
trailer park
how is it different from an apartment or
a house I lived in bad Apartments too
like remember when I told you I lived in
a neighborhood where I was kind of like
the only white kid that's why I never
I'll never let a person tell me that
race is the reason why they can't make
it
because I know too many people of too
many different nationalities and I
believe that real love is dark and if
you really love somebody you'll shake
them and tell them the truth even at the
expense of them getting upset with you
I'll never let them say that because
they're
short or tall or Muslim or Christian or
atheists are black or white or Spanish
that they can't
achieve what they want to achieve in
life because I believe that
the only people that believe in race are
all these other things are the ones that
you're either not willing to do the work
or want to get
affirmation that they wouldn't have made
it anyway but I don't believe that and I
want there's two like I have a clip that
went really viral about me telling a
black girl
that suppression is and
believing in races for broke people
and I got a lot of support from the
black community because of it
and my point was is there's too many
young black men that follow me that look
to me for advice
there's no way I'm gonna let you
sit here and say that not in front of me
these young men can do it and I know
they can because I know a bunch of women
like bro Brandon Carter if Brandon
Carter is not a winner I'm not a
winner you know
like if that dude's not a winner
Myron and Walt look what they've done in
their lives I've got teammates from
college that have done amazing things
they're black guys there's no
way I'm gonna let some 15 year old kid
believe he can't succeed in life because
he's black
I grew up in his neighborhood too for a
little while
and I grew up in trouble so what
you know it really goes back to like
what are you are you gonna take control
of your life I always say the best day
of a man's life is a day he realizes
that nobody's come to save them
if he can know that
and feel peace about it and almost be
excited about it because he gets to go
fight his own Heroes Journey
he'll win if he can accept it 'll win
because you take entire responsibility
for your life too many people give up
responsibility in your life so they
point the finger at somebody else if you
take all of it even when it's not your
fault I've had to do this so many times
to clear around hiring
you take responsibility for everything
regardless of whose fault it is or the
market or a race or religion or who's
present I'm gonna give a who's
President I'm gonna win no matter what
your blind grandmother could be
president I'm gonna win I'm gonna get up
I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna do the
same thing I did yesterday
because I know what I'm gonna do I agree
with that and I would just I just refuse
to let a young man believe that based
off his skin color it's and if
I really love them I could say the
politically correct thing
like yeah I know you know you're so
suppressed it's so sad bro you
can win and I'm not gonna sit you can
get mad at me if you want but I love you
enough to tell you the truth because
that is the truth and I know too many
winners of all ethnicities all Races
religions for me to say anything else
and it goes right back to that thing
about being true to yourself
I'm not going to sit there and let him
believe alive not if I can help it
because
a lot of people have relationships where
a guy's up in their life and
they're supposed to be friends that guy
walks out of the house at let's say a
group setting and they talk about how
that guy's up
that's not love
is taking that in the back
room like hey bro you're up and
I don't care if you're mad at me you
need to fix this now and you'll
stand in the fire of him being angry
with you and you don't give a
because you actually love him that's
what love looks like to me and that's
why I say Real Love is dark
you know
I'll tell you another thing if we're in
let's say I just said this to Ryan today
let's say me and you are on a real
estate deal
and I disagree with you on a subject
I'm not going to disagree with you in
front of him
I'll wait until we get
it's just me and you and I'll ruthlessly
take up for you
because back to the Loyalty thing back
to the Doc Holiday thing I got a bunch
of friends I don't I don't have a bunch
of friends I got a handful of friends
that
put on the line for each other man so I
think that's good etiquette it was Dave
was it Dave Ramsey we were talking about
you met Dave Ramsey yeah we did how was
it actually going back
a month did y'all argue all right
we had a conversation
yeah he's amazing he's awesome Dave is
the nicest guy like I was Starstruck I
got this super so cool you know it's
really funny
because of like the way that like I'm
looked at online sometimes
there's people that I assume will hate
me Dave Ramsey's on that list
and then I have a list of people that I
really hope I meet them before before
they get an opinion of me theovan's
number one because I mean bro both I
love the ovonne and I'm like I
saw him I saw him when he was here in
Vegas please let me meet the obon so we
can talk about white trash
and bologna sandwiches on Trailer Park
porches and alligators and and like
that before he sees some dumb clip of
somebody saying I'm a so that's
all yeah yeah there's definitely looks
like do you have do you have like a like
a list of people you want to meet that
you've not met yet oh yeah we have a
whole Stevo is on that list I really
wanted I really wanted me to see it bro
but he's cool as bro uh Rob Dyrdek
so uh Tony Hawk Jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson would be on there yeah I
actually said some stuff about Jordan
recently yeah you know you know I I
won't say I regret it but I wish I would
have framed it differently because I
super like him and I think he's done a
lot for society I think it it did come
off as though you do like him so that
was just me as a casual viewer it didn't
seem like you like him it was just the
fact that you disagreed with some way
that you could have understood what he
did as hypocrisy yeah and I did feel
that way a bit
um and also I just that morning I
watched a video because I brought it up
and that's actually what I don't like
about it because I think he's a great
man and I brought it up and that's kind
of what I don't like about it but I was
watching a video I think he I watched a
video about something he was saying
about Tate that morning it was just on
my mind and I thought to myself I'm like
this guy definitely knows him you know
but you know it is what it is if I saw
Jordan Peterson I'd tell him how
great he is I mean he he's a very
impactful man and and I think he's
helped a lot of people and I really
respect him a lot I think Tom billyeu
articulated very well the level of
stress and struggle that Jordan Pearson
had gone through before he resulted to
going on antidepressants and stuff like
that which is like I mean
impossible to conceptualize but then but
then also in all fairness
who the am I to say that he can't
get on life is hard bro if
antidepressants helped him I'm not here
to judge him I'm not Jesus you
know what I mean like that's I think I
think that's a great model to live by
and it's something I've learned where
like beforehand when I was 19 and I
thought I knew who I was and who I
wouldn't be I would think no I know
what's better that's what I like about
and I have the ability to judge other
people because I think I know more than
they do but then in the past couple of
years I've had like dose after dose
after dose of like oh this is kind of
what life is like and it's hard bro open
to my brain and removed the capability
of judging people not entirely of course
because everyone judges people it's just
human nature right but like for the most
part yeah I think it's speaking
negatively or speaking on someone else
and that was the point with Dave Ramsey
yeah I think and you would have been in
the room and if it wasn't him I
apologize we were talking about managing
style and he said one of his biggest
regrets early in his career was that he
uh spoke negatively to an employee that
they were doing a bad job in front of
other people and he should have done
that in private and it wasn't in front
of like a large room it doesn't matter I
think it was just in front of other
people and this was early in his career
and he apologized to that employee later
on and corrected the behavior but I
think it's speaking on other people on
public matters yeah maybe for them a
little bit more private exactly and
that's that's what I actually don't like
about it regardless of my opinion
because I respect the man I actually
like Michaela you know what I'm saying I
would love to have her on the podcast
bro she asked me to come on yes dude
come on yes she did no I think it's a
sneak attack I think she saw what I said
so I told her I want to talk to you
because I want to clear this up with her
because I actually respect the girl and
I like her and I like Jordan well
I want to get her on the phone but she
was kind of cool with me she's kind of
like oh we'll just email I'm just like
sneak attack it might be worth it I
would do it yeah
maybe so maybe so man I've said things
online before the great learning
experience and so then they hate ten
years to make it I'm not scared of it
yeah here's what I don't want
I my goal is to
love some people
and in the past
a couple years I've gone on a lot of
shows where it turns into like this
angry thing bro I ain't angry person
those podcasts will make you sound angry
and I also talk a certain way you know I
talk kind of aggressively I curse a lot
you know and I just want to have good
relationship with people it's
particularly people where you know I
respect your dad you know I don't like
what he said about my friend but that
doesn't make me
a person that should be judging him and
that's what I don't like and I brought
it up you know what I mean but
any any man's gonna any man that can
self-reflect at all
should be able to say that publicly I
don't have any issue with that man I
know who I am and I like the girl I
think she's cool you know I spoke I've
spoken to her previously
and um I found her like I found her to
be really cool man so maybe I will maybe
I'll just reach out to her and just tell
her yeah man but and at the very least
you hear a different perspective and
that's something that I've been really
pushing myself on is to hear out other
perspectives and pick and choose the
things that I resonate myself and then
incorporate them into my own life yeah
and that's something that I've been
definitely exploring you've been doing a
good job let me just take one minute
right here no we don't use it no no 10
seconds because when I met Graham and
for the first couple of years I knew him
he was so in his own lane and very very
very just like stubborn just like
headstrong he knows who he is these are
his opinions and values and no one can
inflict any of their like opinions or
values onto him but recently he's been
doing a very good job at being truly
open-minded I'm very happy for him it's
actually super easy for me to do it yeah
um
but on some of those shows it's not
you know to hear somebody out yeah but
um coming on these types of podcasts and
again I can't emphasize enough
I'm so grateful to the guys that
believed in me in the beginning and
brought me on their shows and I will
continue to go on their shows
I would just like to represent myself
holistically that's all I'm saying I do
think it's okay to be strong and know
what you're about and know what you
believe in and not have to on
people what would you improve about the
red pill space where do you think the
weaknesses are there that you could help
better there are some really good women
in this world
really good women trustworthy loyal
good mothers
you know
um intelligent
can help you make money
I'm not saying the rep Hill space
doesn't say that but I think by and
largely there's a feeling that women are
not as smart
or they're not
as good as men and I think that
men and women
are equal because we won't have any
humans without women
but in completely different ways and
what they bring to the table
and I don't have a problem with that
you know I really don't
and I think sometimes based on how some
of the conversations go and I'm not just
talk I'm not talking about freshman I'm
talking about like the red pill space
that doesn't get projected I don't feel
that gets projected
in the correct way
and you ever heard of red pill rage
Now red pill rages this thing
that men go through when they get red
pilled because they realize and they can
see things they've never seen before
it's very real thing I felt a little bit
of it before
um
and
I think the the full maturity of that is
getting to the other side of that
you know anger when you find out that
maybe girls might act a certain way or
maybe certain things that you but like
like a lot of guys get really really
hurt and damaged
because they bring flowers they do
everything she said they're a simp
they have no frame they've watched too
many rom-coms and they think that's how
love works and it doesn't it's not in
the real world and they get really upset
when they when they lose that girl or
they can't even get that girl and she
goes for the guy
and when they start to understand some
of the things that the red pill space
teaches which by the way is super super
important right up there with
understanding money is female nature to
me after Fitness
then they get a little angry and bitter
and upset about that but I think the
full maturity of it is to let them know
that there are really good women out
there and that you can have a good
relationship and all women aren't hoes
and all women aren't trash and a lot of
them you can work with and make money
with
because they're smart my issue with it
would I think that they could improve on
is similar to what you said like the way
that they say things implies and there's
a bit of a subtext of like females or
women being like inferior you know what
I mean like I'm explicitly saying it but
subconsciously that would be the way
language language that their women are
bad they're bad like language I think
Tom Billy who said this or maybe it was
formosi language is how you understand
how Rosie is second on my list behind
Theo of guys I want to meet before they
don't like me yeah dude I think he's a
but language language is his wife
too that's a great example is amazing
bro oh yeah she's incredible bro
bruh she's a beast 100 but anyways
language is the way that you understand
it it's not how you're actually putting
out the words and I think a lot of
people can understand that language in a
way that shows that women are bad and
it's not explicitly what they're saying
it's not which is the language what
you're saying is how it says it's being
is this the language I don't like is it
it seems very victim mentality
from what I've seen and heard from the
red building so like hey you know I'm a
victim of this and that let's go and
on the women I don't enter and
bicker about it like that's I slightly
different disagree with that I think
that
they're sharing with you the things that
can happen to you and what women
actually want I do think that's I cannot
that like I think the red pill space
saves lives I really do I think it saves
guys from often themselves
I really believe this I know that Rolo
is saying and Myron and Walt and some of
the other guys that are in the space
have really helped guys
develop in a way and create better goals
and start working out understanding what
to look for in a woman so they don't a
lot of guys just pick a bad woman
because they don't know any better they
go only off a pretty they don't know the
signs to look for and for that reason
Myron and Walt are saving lives bro I'm
just keep using them because I'm close
to them but I think they're absolutely
necessary
you know
um
that said
it wouldn't feel right to me to not give
the other side of red pill rage
and what my experience has been and the
only thing they can say to me at that
point oh is because you're a chad
okay cool bro but I know a bunch of guys
that aren't chats that have really good
relationships with women there's a lot
of good ones out there
you just need to know where to look and
to find them and how to set your frame
up with them and you also have to
maximize every part of your life
so you're in a position where she wants
to get inside your frame because I think
that's mostly what it's about a woman
wanting to be inside the frame of a man
one thing that you said that actually
was really interesting is that you don't
need to have game you don't need to be
able to spit you don't need to be able
to like be smooth with your words and
pick up girls and stuff like that but
you need to just be that guy yeah that's
because when you're that guy you absorb
women and they act completely different
around you which I actually think is
like I don't know how much women prefer
to be hit on and have games spit on them
and stuff like like I don't know if that
makes them necessarily feel that special
but if they see a dude who's just like
walking through like a chat not in the
way that you know what I mean but like
like being that guy being that guy
they're like oh you know but you know
what being that guy allows you to do
just be honest
that's true see I think it's just being
unapologetically yourself that if you
own whatever you want correct even
whoever's finding that attractive would
be would gravitate but you know it most
often creates the ability to
unapologetically be yourself is to
handle all those areas of your life
that's actually what gives you the
confidence yeah it's the woman
that a young man walks up to because he
learned how to nag somebody from a
pickup coach
and say ah you're kind of okay or you're
a little fat to make her feel insecure
to even out that balance that's never
going to work long term but if you're
that guy
you can either help her get in shape or
you can find a girl that you're actually
attracted to and walk right up to her
and say excuse me
I couldn't help but notice you're pretty
and it would have bothered me very badly
I'd have been upset with myself if it
didn't come say hello hi my name is
Justin
what's wrong with that because the truth
of the matter is
if you're going to DM a girl and say hey
I think you're beautiful let's go get a
drink or whatever that is or Miami or
whatever a hundred guys a day tell her
that and they're not that guy you could
say the exact same thing to that girl
and she'll respond completely
differently and that's why I think the
red pill is helping a lot of people
because it's putting people on the right
purpose to put themselves in a position
to be that guy yeah well I think on that
then it's also the frame and the posture
and eye contact and you know so many sub
Communications
exactly I made the joke on it I think I
said it on fresh and Fit I said I yeah
like bro I can literally
you know you could take a guy who has
not taken care of his business in life
right
and he could send 100 messages that says
hey you're beautiful Miami question mark
could take a guy that has all of his
together
and he could send another 100 messages
to that same group of girls and said hey
and
the guy that had taken care of his stuff
that is that dude probably get more
responses than the other guy haha you're
so mean or I'll fight your just whatever
you know I really think absorbing women
is way better than chasing him anyway
if you're that guy and you're around and
you're kind
and you talk to them and treat them like
a person the crazy the craziest thing uh
people like act like I'm crazy the
fastest way to sleep with a woman is try
not try to sleep with her
her whole life every especially
beautiful women her whole life
men are either cat calling her because
they're below they're probably well
below her and don't think they can get
her anyway they might as well swing for
the fence or
men are aggressively trying to sleep
with their whole life she's like dodging
penis you know her whole life the second
she gets boobs especially beautiful
women so if you sit there and treat her
like she's not this alien
because she's so beautiful like bro
she's gonna like drop her hands she's
like wait a second he's not trying to
drop
stick her ass you know what I'm saying
you know I'm not going in the direction
tonight yeah
but no because now what you're doing is
like girls are like oh this guy's being
nice to me he just wants to get in my
pants you know what I mean like I feel
like that's a dangerous message to share
as no that's not what I'm saying that's
not what I'm saying what was the boom
part that well the boom part is what is
this in the Boom Part what is this
member okay let me look yeah it is but
but the point I'm trying to make
is so many guys
are very clearly and obviously trying to
sleep with the girl
trying to sleep with her
if you can just treat her like a normal
person not put her on a pedestal but not
treat her like
and talk to her just like I'm talking to
you
and get to know that person women want
connection
you know what I mean and
if you're ever what I just thinking of
Josh doing that clip right yeah that's
too funny wow yeah it is bro but it is a
really good analogy because men are
aggressively hitting on women all the
time and she's like you know if you can
just be there in her space and she's
like man this person's really nice to me
and I don't I don't feel like he's like
you know you know what the difference is
it's going in with the intention of
expecting or wanting something yes
versus not wanting something went to a
conversation we're meeting something
from the other person
yeah and that's why I don't believe in
pickup lines because it's almost like
you have your dick behind your back and
you're gonna get her with it like no bro
like hey you're very you look really
pretty today I want to tell you it would
have bothered me if I like I literally
why is it always your line every time
you say because it's honest
because it's completely honest
say the line
it was I just said it a minute ago it's
like hey I couldn't help but no shoot it
really bothered me if I wouldn't have
came to say hello and I felt like a
coward see I would have given you my
number yeah of course bro
because it's also vulnerable
but it's also very bold especially
you're not infusing you know how it
makes me want to know more well and then
also remember how you set up like I have
that presence yeah bro I'm looking her
dead if you walk up like excuse me
I do it no no no no oh this is I'm
really glad I'm really glad you can talk
for you man but just so glad you said
that because I really do like this I'm
like excuse me
I I see it was on bass like there's no
way she can hear me do you purposely
deepen your voice a little bit I I do it
loud enough and deep enough where
there's no second guessing and then I'll
tell you another thing that I'll do I
can't think of the last time it didn't
work
it's been
quite a while
let's say you're in a grocery store
women will put themselves in your space
if they're interested if they're not
interested in you
and it's even a thought that you might
hit on her she'll go the other in the
grocery store
I've seen so I'll be look let's say I'm
at the grocery store at the gym
and I'm working out
a woman will I watch women do this all
the time they'll come and they'll start
working out like within 10 to 15 feet of
me women generally are running for men
so if you're in the grocery store or in
the library on campus or something like
that and you're a young guy and that
girl puts herself in your space she's
trying to tell you to do it sometimes a
lot of the time a lot of time it's been
my experience it's been very rare and
I'll tell you another thing I do to
practice that
it's like once a day I try to give a
person a compliment where I don't want
anything that's a good that's a good I
like when you say that you were supposed
to talk to five strangers a day yeah
yeah good yeah yeah one of them not all
of them no but I didn't know I did a
couple I did a couple so one of my
favorite things to do is to is to
particularly walk up to a woman
um
and and say excuse me same way it's good
practice excuse me
I don't want anything from you but I
just wanted you to know that I think you
look very pretty today and I love doing
it to kind of older ladies you know make
sure you look really pretty today have a
good day and just walk the away
I'll tell you a couple things that does
that's good for practice it is so good
for your soul man it's so good for your
soul just to give somebody a
compliment anytime I'm not feeling like
there's something bad's going on or
whatever I start complimenting people
immediately
and for whatever reason like it like
charges my soul that would stick with
the person for probably a few days a
thousand percent you walk away
especially from a tall handsome
like me
show them the bottom two ads yeah but yo
once you know you're pretty
but yeah man like
um
also have this other technique I don't
know I feel like I'm teaching games and
talking about fighting games like I'm
trying to say what but I do have this
technique called the backboard technique
okay so let's say there's a pretty girl
in line at the grocery store you start a
conversation with the old lady in front
of you or behind you or in the vicinity
right
so she can see you're building a rapport
with like somebody that's obviously a
not it's not a non-sexual thing right
but that other person gives you
validation that you're not a creep you
know what I'm saying like you're not
being creepy and so you start
that conversation with that person and
then you can Loop here and what do you
think about this you know that's good
and that works I'll tell you
another thing that works I love going to
Honky Tonks
it's like a country bar okay you know
swinging spinning the girls dancing
cowboy boots
I have a rule it's called first of all I
really like to dance but
I always say my friends laugh at me I
said I don't care if she's 80 or 280.
I'm dancing with these and one
of the best things you can ever do is
walk up to a group of women when there's
a very beautiful girl in the group and
grab that fat girl and just spin her ass
and laugh and cut up and just have a or
the old lady boom spinning around that
girl sees you
and you're putting the weird walls down
and you're doing it indirectly
I was at a bar this was probably like
eight months ago on Catalina Island off
of like bro I've been there multiple
times since you've been happening on
Earth bro yeah bro dude my buddy's got a
sailboat go there all the time but not
three times anyways
I think I've actually been twice as well
I went to this bar on Catalina Island I
was dancing with this old woman yeah
very old woman uh but I was so confident
I went up on the stage and everything
there's a little cage in this bar I was
in the cage dancing with the old woman
afterwards this girl comes up to me hey
my friend really thought you were cute
of course she did you're dancing it was
the girl I thought was cute as well so
it's a key that worked out yeah yeah a
thousand percent man it works every time
it's beautiful I can't dance
please teach them I feel so
uncomfortable bro you put me try to get
a little dance lessons
you put like I already I already wear
tight jeans bro you put me in some tight
jeans and some cowboy boots and a
t-shirt
on that just out of curiosity okay is
this just the style that you landed on
that Euro like big fan of my jeans yeah
no bro I've tried so hard
it's so difficult I have a 32 waist
36 long and my quads and hamstrings so
why don't you just get wider pain yeah
custom-made bro I've tried I've tried
almost I'll tell you what happens it's
like it gets weird in my crotch and I
want to be stylish and it doesn't even
really bother me like I get it all day
long bro people hate on me so hard for
that Bro them I got a
world-class ass them I don't care
you don't think that like like bro
you're not gonna hurt my feelings no I'm
not trying to hurt your feelings how bad
is this though how bad is it let me see
ah it's actually not that bad yeah I
mean it's oh you do it huge butt yeah
bro that's it's tight yeah it's a little
tight I mean
the thing is it fits it's just it's just
the
the inseam do you work out your glutes
dude I squat yeah you do okay yeah dude
I spent I spent most of my youth in a
squat rack yeah the thing is when you
stand up and you adjust them they don't
look that tight but when people catch
you in precarious situations maybe
they're getting a stride or something
like that and then it could really grip
around the bro I'll be honest with you
bro I don't give a yeah I really
don't care then honestly I think that's
what's attractive
yeah I don't bro like I've tried all
kinds of jeans
and bro in fact if you were to go to my
closet in Louisiana I better have over
50 pairs only over trying to find the
right fit
you know but
it is what it is man I'm not mad so
they're not skinny jeans these are like
normal jeans no no they're boot cut
jeans I thought they were skinny no
bro they're not skinny jeans they're all
no they're athletic give you guys
they're athletic cut jeans I'm buying
these workout jeans there's the Walmart
jeans that I wear uh that are boot cut
yeah bro those aren't skinny jeans I
can't even give my cab in skinny jeans
no you don't understand they do you know
how you know how I know yeah they do a
ratio whatever your waist is they do
some sort of ratio to your thigh
I waist to thigh ratio doesn't work
you know what I'm saying now look I
could go get really baggy jeans but I
also look like a goober why
don't you just wear a belt like I get
scared I do but what happens is when I
put the belts so I've tried this right
I've tried about 36 waist so my thighs
will fit
but it never tailors outright and then
when I put a belt on
I'm that dude that has pants on that are
too big and it all crinkles up and it's
all right you're very custom
I've done custom
I've not I've never found a guy that
could make it work you know and it is
what it is they don't have enough fabric
when they're making the pants I don't I
don't know I don't know eyes large
enough I don't know what it is man but
you know what
it's never slowed me down
you know this Cliff is gonna get so many
views because it's the I love Ryan
pineda's haircut yeah his haircut is
dope yeah you get to cut like
once a week once a week
never seen a hair it's immaculate it is
Flawless that is a handsome
oh yeah he's gorgeous thanks bro Jesus
anyway
um now I'm gonna get called Gay good
it's perfect people call Grandma and I
that all the time bro I get called all
kinds of someone comment this like
did you see the way Graham looked at
Jack the other episode are they dating
bro you know what's funny about that you
know like I uh-oh
going online you really realize how
people can be or they
got nothing to do like they're talking
about my jeans on the internet
it was funny it was funny to me what's
funny to me is there's a guy that said
that five comments ago bro it's not even
authentic at this point to make fun of
me for my jeans I get like I don't give
a man you like I truly don't
care but yeah man I'm still buying
drains I try all the time we constantly
buying jeans
issues I think if you were to wear
sneakers it would balance out the
silhouette because you're wearing the
the dress loafer and I think when you go
from you know my Cowboys my cowboy boots
are sleeping tapers I wanted to taper
that's good Style
it's good style I think if you worse
like some Nike sneakers I've got Barber
I've got barbell jeans I've got all
these like jeans for people that work
out I've just not found the right pair
man and honestly I think it's a good
pair of shoes I think you like it a
little bit and I don't think there's a
dude I do yeah there we go there we go
I'm super not sorry about it yeah like I
wish I could paint them on
because I got an ass and legs that you
ain't never seen bro and and I worked
really hard for it and why wear jeans
why not just go with the shortest
leggings
Nike shorts that I wear with like
button-ups and not button them to like
right here so my like my whole chest is
out and it's like a Miami Vibe look
and I'll wear like that white Nikes with
the socks like the halfway socks like oh
yeah yeah I do that yeah I'm sure
somebody has something to say about that
but that's pretty much my same response
is get some of this because you know
I'll work hard for this ass bro should
jack unbutton that top button yeah you
look like a nerd bro that's really yeah
I always tell them I would do up here if
I could but then if you had if you had a
chest you wouldn't I'd do it just check
it out
got plenty of Hair there too it's like I
think this looks a lot more relaxed I do
too man I like it why don't you say it
if we're boys wouldn't you tell me I
wasn't really looking for it honestly if
I don't know this it would have said
something all right well now now I'll
just there we go I do think that you
should shave your neck
I did shave my neck you know I'm talking
about to hear I did no like you see all
this under here oh this yeah man so so
that beard can come in no no okay so my
brother told me like when I first
started grinding you go like this just
double chin that it makes shave all that
line when the are you walking
around like this well I'm just saying
because if you go right yeah if you go
up too high then it looks no you should
go up to it because like I would leave
like a half inch underneath it so it
falls under here because you're taken
away from your jawline bro it like
you're you're literally robbing your own
jawline by doing it like that yeah
yeah because your jaw your jawline is
blending into your neck hair
you need to at least come to the
underneath part I can do that you should
I'll try it out it's just my brother
told me that as soon as it started
growing up because I've just been doing
that my entire life people that come to
me they're like Jack you have a beard
how do you trim it I say collect this go
along the line no bro no you need to go
like this and shave up to under your
jawline and let it go right under your
jawline because you have this you have
you have really good beard like outline
right thank you
um if you were to shape like and you
also have a jawline but you take away
from it because it Blends into your neck
yeah yeah anyway I don't know I think
it's fine the way it is
probably it's better it'll be better the
other way I don't know what it would
look like we should do it after the show
do you have a razor we should get a
razor
I'll do it I'll do it when I go home
it's yeah yeah all right so
I'm very open to keep talking to you but
I have to give you guys some
gotify so I had to do a little research
um and I did so
you like Pokemon yeah yeah I thought so
so this set came from Japan
you can only get it in Japan the guy
that got it had to go to Japan to get it
so he was super excited about I don't
know a thing in fact there are
some kind of Pokemon tournament when I
went to the place
if I've ever seen an incel in real life
it was probably in that room the Pokemon
yeah I like Pokemon they were looking at
me like I had a dick growing out of my
forehead like what is this doing
in here what's turbo chat doing it here
buying after this I got to show you
buying these collectors cards but these
came from Japan straight from Japan
never opened
that's so cool yeah yeah so Paul wait so
how did you get these from Japan there
was the guy got them from Japan I'm like
what is the most specialty thing you
have and he's like bro I got this set of
cards never opened I had to go to Japan
to get it is this something that you're
supposed to open or no I would like to
open it no don't don't ask me don't ask
me well thank you man that is very nice
of you yeah he put up like yeah
that's kind of how he was like showing
off that he had it yeah you can't get
this in America you got to fly to Japan
to get a smart thing to do yeah do not
open that Jack yeah it'll probably be
worse it's worth some money now but I
think it'll be worth money later thanks
man I appreciate it so you my friend
I really appreciate your content I've
been watching it for years thank you I
enjoyed it you're way cooler than I
thought you'd be
um
but I'm not surprised anyway there's
this family I know you do drums right
all right cool there's this family
that's supposed to be this special
family and they hand make
um like I guess what is it called when
you hit the soap like the the metal
thing symbol the symbols yeah so this
one is a handmade seminal serious yes no
I did I gotta show you the drums the
family yeah I don't know about it
but the family made it by hand yeah and
their thumb prints is still on it so
dude this is insane you probably know
this family you've heard of these people
Brazilian of course yeah oh my gosh yes
no way yeah and um
and so here I'll probably just turn it
around but
see if I can get here somehow all right
so
whoa
I wouldn't I can't play with it no you
can't yeah okay good yeah it was like so
I guess I'll get some beef this is
number this is number 14. wow
what
wow how are you supposed to display this
I don't know
I only got to find a way to frame this
sick dude thank you so much thanks for
the cards man that's cool man yeah he
also broke a record on the uh iced
coffee hour I think it's become apparent
what the record we broke today what was
it three hours oh yeah three hours 45
three hours 35 maybe 35 yeah
second longest Brett Cooper both of you
yeah she was this bro was it yeah
speaking of Mike
speaking of Brett Cooper
bro I respect her
I think she's a pretty girl I'm not like
crazy attracted to or anything but a
super respecter I hate that she hates me
I don't super care but I know that if I
would have met her in any other
circumstance we get along just fine dude
we should have reached out how to do a
message I should have yeah we had we had
Ben Shapiro on the podcast recently bro
I feel the same way about him I love Ben
Shapiro I like I love Brit Cooper I
think it's funny that she hates me like
I'm not upset about it she mentioned
your jeans too of course she did of
course she did like bro I'm an easy
person to make fun of like and and
I'm also a person that people would like
to make fun of you know but I don't give
a it's all good I still love her
you know it's all good and I love Ben
Shapiro so I don't care I don't have
time to be hating people man just the
wrong energy in the wrong direction well
you know what you could put it out there
there's a chance you'll see this and
you never know what might happen I don't
really have any intentions other than
you know saying that I don't have
anything against or not I like and
respect her a lot and I feel the same
way about Ben well yeah and Jordan
Peterson so if they want to hate me they
can but I'm a good person I know that
and I'm very confident that if I were
ever to have the opportunity to meet her
and she would give me a chance to talk
to me she'd like me
you know we might agree on one thing or
another there's no way she wouldn't like
me no way so cool cool with that
said thank you guys so much for watching
really appreciate it thank you for being
here thank you for coming on this has
been great I've enjoyed it very much
thank you
sincerely for that this is INS again I
just gotta find a way to frame it so
thank you sounds good